You
Let's see how this works. I don't know where the game went. Hey gone. Oh, there it is
They and Samara was good. How do I sound? I don't know. Does this $400 thing make a difference. I
Bet I sound the same
I
Was asleep watching strong even she rated it from here would have been perfect but an animal give all
Tyler one Mike sounding great. You think it does make a difference. Does it sound worse?
It was a comfy, okay, I'm glad you guys like the ASMR
I sound clear, but I'm peeking. I I had a feeling that would happen
Let's see if I can fix that
You look broken I can fix that sorry I
Guess I can I have a playback in my headphones and I do sound I just a bit
Just a wee bit peeky
Just a wee bit
And I don't know if that would be the gain perhaps I
Turn that down just a tad. I don't know. I don't know if that helped
When is the peaking it sounds really good, okay, I don't know why it like peaks am I like too close?
I don't even know how I would fix that to be honest with you
That's better
A lot better
Yeah, yeah, I'm glad
Wait, did I lock my door my doors unlocked hold on I
Went downstairs
Packages and I forgot to lock the door as per usual nothing new there
What do you mean, what do you mean, please? What do you mean, please? I
Want to see what the delay is on this
It's been weird
I can't tell it's not showing me
Oh
Why does it keep doing that? I'm like, come on come on
Huh, I don't know if it's like something in my settings like either or it will
Be like a little bit behind but it's fine. I'm mostly gonna be
Playing anyway, so we don't have to have like super live interaction. Oh
YouTube you silly silly silly Billy
All right
Sorry, I'm happy cuz and that's why my voice is getting higher. I
Know some people are like, why is she talking in an ooo voice? I'm sorry when I get happy
I talk in my ooo voice. I can't help it. I'm excited to play the game and spend time with you guys
Hello
He is meowing to herself while she's playing with her toy. Okay, so yeah, I've never played this before
I've never watched anything about it. I know nothing about it besides Greek gods and I love Greek gods in Greek mythology
So I'm like so ready to get into this
And you guys know I love called the lamb and you guys said it's a roguelike and
I've seen the art before like I've seen the art of Aphrodite when that was going viral and I was like wow
I love his art style
so
I'm very happy
Rain is still running around all hyper she's napping right now, but I was so surprised I was like, oh, what the heck?
What are you doing?
She was
He's looking at me now actually she just like I think she heard her name
She's watching the other cats play with the toy, but yeah, she was playing with I was like crying
Because I was so happy to see her playing
It's it was really funny. She like
Poop and then had the zoobies. I'm like, are you serious? Did you just really need to take a shit? Oh
Wait, this is look what I can do now. Holy
Oh my god
Oh
Is the game you did. Oh, yes, I think accidentally muted it
There you go, I don't know if you guys can hear it the little beep noises
So anytime I swear I can just be like, oh, I hate the I can't believe this
It's quiet. Okay, hold on. I'm turn that shit up. Oh
My is that
I
Realize you guys are like in my head like a bit smaller
But I think hold on let's can we just mess could we just hang out and mess around for just a moment
It's just just for a quick momento
What if you beep before you say the word and still say the word what the
Language lady I
Can also mute with this thing wait, hold on. I want to see I don't know if reverb works
I don't know if it works because I can't with the
My mic monitor doesn't tell me if anything's changing. So I don't know if I have reverb
So you guys can tell me my cat is attacking my freaking
What are they called slippers
Have we not always been the voices in your head all the things you said all the things she said right through my head
But he asked you guys
I
Don't know if also like this works. I don't know if this works. I'm a is it giving me a robot voice you tell me
Fia, can you please stop chewing on my foot? I beg you please let go of my slipper
Did it work, I don't know again chats delayed so I'm just sitting here like oh
Is it working and I'm just being goofy
I
Don't know why she's attacking my slippers. Boomi was doing it earlier, too. It doesn't work. Okay, that's weird
I have to figure that out then
What if
What if I do this no, this is gonna that'll mess everything up, but I have set up
Yeah, I think there's like something I have to do where I can route it through
The thing but it doesn't do that for some reason
Cuz like I'll press stuff and like pressing robot voice, but then I
Can't hear anything
And then I'm turning up the reverb on my computer instead of on my
XLR and so doesn't do anything. I
Don't know why it is what it is. What are your toes? No, I just took a shower. I don't know what you're talking about
I just took a shower. I just took a shower
Wait a second did I figure it out
I don't know if that does anything. Is it working?
Je ne sais pas
My feet aren't stinky ever got what she was is this for YouTube because Twitter's ocean marks don't get displayed in the actual video. Oh
Okay, sorry, I just saw that harlot question. Which stream did the heal mark replace rope? Yeah, cuz the rope doesn't come up
It neither does the other bunny emo
So this is what you can use instead if you would like to use my oh she marks, which I appreciate
I
So weird
Oh, I'm gonna Google this
This is our pre chat. This is our pre pre game chat. Okay?
how to make
Go XLR effects work on
Oh, yes
People I can't read forums they just confuse me. I don't know anything about I
Don't know anything about audio. I'm not audio literate at all
40 minutes pre chat of me just messing around with my go XLR
Hey, at least it's not like five hours that it took with me and Azura
She was helping me with all of my audio and
Also my 3d audio and so was mercy at some point she popped in because I was doing an illicit stream to test it and
The girl said it sounded fine and
And as there is like if anyone complains it's them and I'm like bet
and people complained it's you guys whatever
and
But we still weren't able to figure out how to get the effects to work
Um on there, so I think I need to do more research. I asked my manager and my manager is like how the fuck am I
They were just like I don't have one. I'm like, okay. I thought you just knew everything. I'm so sorry
Excuse me
But I buy one off Craigslist and send it to them be like show me how to use this
How to use voice effects
With go XLR
Is this person gonna show me how
Why is he who makes a video and has themselves so far away from the camera so you can't see what people are doing
I don't understand did anybody comment with some
This is making my brain hurt
I'll do this after I wanted to show you guys but
Percy Jackson mentioned did you watch the live action one? I thought it was pretty good
Let me just click on one of these what is a gender knob am I
Am I gonna turn into a man if I
Why is that an audio thing? I don't know what that means
Echo it's the type of echo that you understand. Oh now that one's a multi-tap and really
Sorry, it was the video I wish I had subtitles so I can read. Oh it does
Cool do I double tap it to make it work?
No, all right
FX
No, I'm just like putting reverb on my voice. Although it doesn't exist
At least the beep works. That's all I care about. What the f*** if you look at me with your dumb
Face I swear to God I'm going to
Mom
Your mom
This is every time I'm plugging it plugging it back in I have
my
Insults are invigorating. I'm glad. Let's see if there's a software update devices up to date global settings
What does that say
Oh, I can connect to my stream deck that's cool. I
Don't really need to do that though
So that means I could probably add more effects to my stream deck that's pretty nifty
Yes, yes indeed
Actually, I am tempted to unplug it and plug it back in
Because it doesn't make sense why the effects wouldn't work at least the microphone part works. I
Don't get it presets big echo big verb
No
Herm interesting. Whoa, that's loud. Holy crap. I just made it louder
Oh, oh my god
Faders
Effects
Because this is this group reverb echo. Yeah, I think it might just be my thing. Maybe I do have to unplug it and plug it back in
samples
ooh
Bro, I'm about to become a dj
Call me icy the way I'm about to become a dj
Okay, let's play shall we presets or presets? I don't know what you're both. Why not both, you know both
Also, make sure
Oh, thanks for the member is equal as well. And oh, let me actually read any don't know for last stream because I've ended stream
Before I could read any don't knows
Nice there is no don't knows
Oh
Nothing to worry about then perfect
Yeah, we're playing already. Well, I just peeked the mic. I'm sorry
All right, and nothing to worry about and there are a pair of super chats. Let me see
Oh
Yeah, you're right. Okay
Wait, is that from the day before hold on stream allowance is weird. Sometimes stuff doesn't load properly
Let me just refresh this page. What if I log out along back in?
App store plays endless zone zero today. I saw that I might play it. I usually don't I haven't played any hoyo
Uh verse games
now I'm tempted
I'm sorry. So there's someone who subscribed to my channel and their name is just oh god
That's funny
All right, there's two super chats from charlie spur
Both two dollars. Thank you charlie. By the way, can we lay in your lap?
And oh, hey, she's not cursed this time
I wish I knew the river the context for those
But that was it
How much prep time have you given percy jackson access to water?
Can I beep her? Oh, yeah, I definitely could in a fight. That's a whole ass child. I could beat him up
I just kick him
Punch. I don't need water. I just find him in the desert
The eyes pop up beautifully under this black screen wow
Wow, wow
My eye color might change when I get the tan toggle. I'm thinking blue eyes
white dragon
But only for the toggle I think
Your muppet is the cursed part. Oh that makes sense
I'll kick him always. What pop what pop?
Okay, I got my controller
I'm so excited to see this. I love how watching different people play this game and someone said there was voice acting
Blue eyes sigmes cat I was thinking um future model
I'll actually be a himalayan rabbit because it's close to a sigmes cat because they have the same gene genetic thing
Where um their extremities are brown because of the change in temperature
Are you familiar with this game not at all?
Hit him with them
We get it you have blue eyes
It's fully voiced
ah sweet
Okay, then I don't have to do anything
Although I could I bet there's an option to
change that though
Yeah
I'm wondering if I should voice act. No, I don't have to I'll let the people talk and I'll just enjoy myself
Chrissy Jackson ends up in a no no no no no stop. I just accidentally smacked my mic smacked my mic
No
Bad
Hell mode
I have no idea what that means. Okay
Few tales are told of hades. Oh whose very name inspires fear and penitence
I don't know. I kind of like them because of laura limpus. Have you read laura limpus?
Very good
Read laura limpus on webtoon everyone
Oh
Oh, I already love this. Goodbye father
Why am I in tartarice?
Am I hades to help with this place?
Oh, I can bump into some ghosts
Interesting
I feel like I walk too fast. Is there is there a walking button? Oh shit. Okay. I can dash
I can crash stuff. Oh, I have a big ass sword. What am I like pericles or something?
I don't know what that is
Whoops, um, okay, I don't know. I can't do that whatever that is
Okay, that's just to move
I think I prefer this than this. Yeah, okay. I think I'm used to it now
I'm John Hades. Okay, gotcha
I'm John Hades
Hold on. I need to get more comfy
This game is so pretty and I only I'm in the fucking tutorial
You know lean back a little bit
Yeah
Whoa, what is going on my chair?
Black silence 26 tipped 15 dollars. Thanks. Black silence. More condiments for the Ushibi
My mom the other day she's just like, how are you doing?
Now I'm like, I'm fine. She's like, have you been eating? Well, and I'm like, yeah, of course
And she's just like send me a picture of your fridge right now
And I did
She's like, oh wow, you have so many condiments in your fridge, Shibi. You have some pickles as well
Wow, you have a lot of good stuff here. How are you gonna make a meal? You're gonna you're gonna put some ketchup with some mustard
And have that as a little snack on some rice cakes that you have and I'm like, maybe maybe I will
Oh
Who are you? Why do you have what is that character from um that one anime demon slayer
Can I like lock on no
Oh, okay, interesting
Am I supposed to like fight them or can I just run past? Oh, okay
Ow
Who the frick are you
I think I might die and it's only the freaking
Tutorial
Oh my god, what the hell? Oh, try and stop me. Yeah, you just might
Uh get these guys
There she is
Who is this got to be her zagroos? There's nothing
In the name of Hades
I accept this message
Zagrus, what is he the god of?
He's a demi god. What is he? I really I recognize his name
Uh, he's he is a son of Hades
Don't tell me
It's not like nightmares
He's pretty eyes. He's a one red one green eye. I love the color palette with the random dash of green. It's very interesting
Hmm. All right, you can tell me what is he the god of?
I got a good one for my first son of the big fella. He's the god of talking smack
Yeah
Hades nuts
Hail noble cousin now, let's get you from that miserable place
I'll see that all of us upon Olympus to our part beginning here with me
Okay, she's goddess of wisdom, you know Athena
It says it there
He's got a blood
He's not Dionysus. Is he a Dionysus counterpart? I'm looking this up because I I like mythology. I'm looking this up
Zagrus is a god associated with rebirth hunting in the underworld
His name translates to great hunter in greek and in the epic Al Simeonus
He is called the highest of all gods Zagrus is also associated with the wine god dying. Oh, okay
Uh, that wine god Dionysus in an orphic tradition. He's considered the first incarnation of Dionysus. Okay. I stand corrected
A son of Zeus and Persephone
What
Oh well
Other stories identify him as a son of Hades or even as Hades himself. Oh, yeah, there's a lot of gods that kind of get like mixed up
Uh
Interesting because there's different forms of myths and
Because like
I
Little odyssey might depict something just as an example might depict a god as this but another
Writing depicts them as this
The name
Zagrus derives from Zagrit, which is properly a pit for catching animals
But also one used for depositing animal remains or offerings to a catholic deity
Making Zagrus literally the god of pitfalls
Hunter that catches living animals or
Direct translation would be catcher of game
I would like to know
Oh, yeah, epic Al Simeonus, Mistress Earth Gaia and Zagrus
Zagreus
I'm say Zagreus highest of all the gods perhaps mean the highest god in the underworld
Interesting interesting
Hold on
Zagreus from the Euripides fragment and suggestive Dionysus
Interesting
This Dionysus Zagreus was a son of Zeus and Persephone he was as an infant attacked and dismembered by the titans
So later aboard as a son of Zeus and some now
assembly
Huh, huh. So I'm just reading the Wikipedia page because Wikipedia is very truthful
Dr. Luke Edgar von Kleist tipped one dollar and fifty cents just say again
Flying money loving the stream again
Again, thank you for the tip
Dr. Luke Edgar von Kleist
Zagreus, yeah
Trust is what the games tell you authors contradict during each other is very common mythologies. Yes
Yes indeed
Oh
Okay, uh
What should I pick?
Which is the best one
I'm gonna sip my drink while you tell me
This makes me want to play play wedding witch wedding which is a fun game
Well, aren't you just the sweetest?
Dr. Luke Edgar von Kleist tipped two dollars and twenty two cents easy
Easy I don't get it
Easy
Three okay
We'll do that then we're all saying three all the way where you are goddess, but thank you
Cool
I don't remember what my dash is
Can't heal myself, but I can fight
I like the voice acting
Oh do I just pick up my diamonds?
How do I dash?
Nope, that's not it. Um
Oh, that's pretty cool. I see it now
Let's go
Hello mates
I like how everyone's British
Why is this thing shooting? Oh, it is pretty strong. Okay. Oh, ow
I am close to death. Oh, okay. Is there like a way I can heal?
I
Just don't step on the thingy. I'll lead them to step on the thingy come over here. You know, you wanna
ow
No, this isn't working if I step on it
Cool
I'm gonna die
I don't wanna oh
Come on
Trying to get them to shoot him
Come on. Come over here. I have four health. Come on down. Why do you walk around it like a dumb?
Oh, I missed
Yeah
It's using using your uh your environment
I don't know what that means. What that?
That's a proceed. Is there something I can pick up for health? Is there something like that? I only have four
I can't heal but I can fight you can dodge attacks if you dash the right moment madam. Okay for health in a dream
I
Triangle for my special
I pressed
I don't know what that is
Oh
That is hardcore I love it holy crap
Damn it. Oh, I must be the god of blood
I'm home
Oh, yes carry on everyone don't mind me
Who's even over here? Welcome to the house of hades. Oh hypnos. I know you I guess I mean you died out there, huh?
Well, don't be sad though. Pretty much everybody dies sometime
Ah hypnos some of us more than others
Back already
Hi dad
Look it's Cerberus. Oh my god puppy
Oh
There's a good boy
You can pet the dog and Hades. Don't scoff at me dad
Oh my god, I love you. I love all the red motifs. I feel like I fit in here
I
Have no should be a patron god to your sleeping ASMR
Somebody else around here. Who's that? I'm gonna guess your persepony
Do not despair child just kidding your next setbacks are inevitable and maybe overcome with effort and with time
We made contact with the goddess Athena. She shall be true to her word. Wow. She is gorgeous
I want to talk to the artists and get a vtuber design from them because holy crap
I
Genuinely love everything about and also hypnos too. I believe it next
I'm grateful that you put us in a contact. What's up with my eye. You know, you took a considerable risk and that's just a stylish thick shadow
The risk is not to me
I expected the olympians would involve themselves in this eventually
Is it next the mother of no more than they already know?
Are we understood?
I have not I have seen aphrodite. He's too. Yes, uh, she is
Fucking
They're all really beautiful
Like I have such an appreciation for character design and level design and I am like trying not to geek out right now
Because I could just stand here and be like, wow
Look how they did this. Wow. Look at that. I can't get around these bones
You've returned
Uh, I don't know who you would be. Maybe like fanatose or something to see your lad killies. What are the circumstances?
The hell remember your training. Oh killies also looks cool. Everybody has like some sort of red on their body, which is very interesting to me
That fear is for the weak take care of killies
Oh
Wait, I didn't tweet that I was live
Where I just started so it doesn't matter that much
Let me not accidentally tweet all my
Oh and in me hit 10k, let's go. I'm so proud of her for getting 10k subs. I'm just so happy for her. Oh my god
Live
Watch me admire all the pretty art and
Character design within babies
Let me retweet that hold on I'm gonna be ventriloquist for a second
I usually will post on my main then retweet it to my alt
So the cool words get to see it
Who is damn hit no she snores so loud, bro
Aesthetics are actually didn't have decent
Killies is a hero of the children war
Well, yes, I know that
I know my great gods guys. Well, he's not a god. He's just a dude
He's a guy that was dipped in the river
For protection, but she only held on by his little achilles heel
And that's where he died and that's why we call it an achilles heel
Come here little guy. Yeah
Oh, they didn't like that. What I wanted to talk to you
Cuz stop stop running away from me
What is that glowing thing
The house of hades that dark and lavishly appointed layer of the underworld's king
Is home not just to him
But to his will, you know, I can hear you old man
Who the heck is the narrating then?
Uh, what the hell?
I was hoping that I could like read about these
Perfects. I just want to pet the dog forever
Can I talk to
Infernal watchdog surplus regards the underworld prince with mixed emotions from purest joy to deepest melancholy
You watch over things for me, won't you boy? You know, I'd take you if I could
Oh, uh, hi dad stupid boy
I told you no that is such a badass design for hades
Who how was your wanton ransacking of my domain?
I love the reverb on his voice
Greetings, father
My ransacking was a delight. Thank you for asking. It really like is the air that we're in a big hall. The echo is really good touch
Be on your way indeed
What do I care?
You shall never reach the surface
Go see for yourself
This is so cool
Because yeah, hades is also the god of like money
And that's a really good touch
That they have like him covered in jewels
Wow, I love it
What's this? Can I see you see these blueprints?
All right, um
Looks like I go this way probably
Hey room, I'm back room
Mirror mirror on the wall. Here's the handsomeest little boy in the mall night in darkness guide me
Okay
Oh, all right, um
Okay, I'm gonna do this one
The power of darkness a power of darkness compels you the bed chambers of prince zagreous lie in a perpetual
Look at my little bed
I have just a child teenage boy room
Repeatedly insisting that he pick everything up second game calls him homer. Oh that makes so much sense then
Then it's homer
That's a good savory snoring he's dragging a chair across the floor
But I know he had a good mustache. Will she be reached the surface?
Do I bet this game is long and I don't just reach the surface
Rest question mark need to sleep
I don't know. Why do you have a bed then you're a freaking god? I like you have a cyclops head
Pretty sick. You have a smaller one. You have a lot of smaller ones
Then you have a gorgon head which it doesn't really make sense that the gorgon head has
Like a skeleton hair but go off this
Excuse me, um
Cool, I like it. Look at my clothes. Do I like to write?
Nifty, so I probably die a lot and come back if I have to come back and reflect often
What is it? Oh, okay, so it looks like I can get hades his pitchfork
A little poker need to find a key and then I'm assuming that's something of
Aries again, I'm just guessing this based off of aesthetic
And then look like uh, Athena's bow. I mean not Athena's bow. What's her name?
Artemis's bow. I can escape through that pink window there
Why do I want to get out so bad? What happened? Why do I hate my dad?
I just want to walk over here first. Oh
I can do this
First get past the retrochates of Tartarus
Easier said than done and doubtless. I'll be running into Meg
I remember flame ought to be just beyond Meg from find a way up to Elysium Hercules
Magara, let's give it another shot
Are this chamber reached five? Okay, cool
What's that? No, keep sex yet. Oh fascinating. Okay
Cool, cool, cool. Hi Nori. I love you too, Nori
It's Achillesphere. Oh, okay ready
Oh music is good too
Thunder is that thunder thunder thunder cats
Zeus
Okay
In the name of Hades Olympus. I accept this message
Why do I have to say the name of Hades if I'm mad at my dad?
Hey, what's up? It's me
Look your father's always been rather difficult. I want to voice acting this game so bad. Just make me a nymph
Where you belong? You're on Olympus
And to help you on your journey have my blessing
Sick
I'm assuming I should pick the rare one
There there's a buy one get one sales on the surface and he needs to get some new shoes
All of the art
He has a little nymph
Technically could beat this game on your first run, but it's definitely not the intent of the developers. You were going to die a lot. Gotcha
Zagreus's name Zagreus name doesn't hold much sway in Olympus. I imagine
Isn't Hades also the name of the underworld?
No all up to me this one's rare
I kind of want the rare one
Okay
Lord uncle Zeus lending his support never thought I'd see the day or night whenever
Oh, no, it's ended too
Ah, oh
Oh, oh fuck. I wasn't paying attention
I don't where's my oh, there's my sword. I have to like summon it into the shit
Shoe
There's blood in the pit. No way to patch up. We've got to keep going
Why does his voice sounds familiar his voice sounds like the narrator from just
Slay slay the princess. That's
I'm so sure that it's him
The underworld of lord Hades. Please somebody look that up
It is a guy who voices Zagreus the same guy that voices the narrator and slay the princess
Good thing i'm not dead
Uh
Sure
What is it now what the fuck is that little skulls?
Is there a lock-on ability because I would like that
Right
Oh, I can blow the candles out and then they read that. Oh, man
I saw that coming from a mile away, but I stepped on it anyways. Ow
Ow
Okay
I'm not good at this game. That's for sure
I'm gonna die again
Will that be all?
I gotta keep something back home. Do I get some health?
Please
Nope, it's not. Oh, they they sound the same
Yeah, I got a dash more
He's only voices. Oh, okay. Gotcha. Gotcha. I uh, I forgot something
I
Call my hair is like red for a second. Sorry. I forgot something
What's up?
Oh, one of those wretched louts just killed you dead that time those mean old slappy guys
Shut up
Uh, oh, what are you?
Some sort of special offer for me my good shade
Okay
I like how I'm just approving this and my dad doesn't care. I don't know what these mean
Oh, this game is a lot more intense than I thought it was
Okay
I can change the I can decorate
I like I was just like a little shade in the ring hard hats. That's so funny. Hi dad
I am the prince of uh
What's it called
Home decoration
One whose responsibility is to work on this house
The who shall pay for everything my subjects here demand. I do not know he voices with zag and hades
really
They don't sound the same. He's very good voice actor
A lot of depth
You can stun the red health enemies like that guys. I'm not gonna listen to any of you. I hope you know that right now
You think I'm gonna remember that I don't even remember how to play
I can't remember what the attacks are half the time
Some are just visual novel you have to read descriptions very difficult roguelikes with dark souls of a difficulty really
All right, you're trying to guilt to me into funding the exorbitant furnishings you desire
Perhaps once we are finished with repairs for all the carnage you have sown throughout my realm
Then we might finally have time for all the needed renovations that have piled up
Okay, nice
Cool. Hi dicks darkness guide you child
You have outgrown this house of that. I am now certain
I won't forget your next size
I like how we're talking like I'm not gonna be back in like five minutes
Do I need to I didn't catch anything so I don't really need to look in the mirror
I should go
Oh, so if I oh
Okay, there we go
Koran oct the heart seeker
Let's deal some depth
Over here. What the
Hold
Whoa
Dr. Luke Edgar von Kleis tipped one dollar and fifty cents I heard again
This is weird
Oh
I almost felt that I like guys just hanging out
Carl Knox, that's a badass name
But I like the sword
It's skelly best character can I talk to him place? He got your boy. Oh name skelly has it going but enough with the smart talk already
I'm here to do a job. So let me have it. Give me everything you got
I don't remember having you on payroll mate. Who's your supervisor?
Wow, the boy's acting so good
Just try and beat it out of me
If you insist
um
Are you like a sucker for pain?
What was the other attacks I could do
That's a volley that's pretty cool. Whoops. Oh, is I not supposed to kill him?
I got you pretty good. Oh, you made me nervous dude. I thought I killed you
And you're just a sucker for pain, aren't you? It doesn't really matter though. You think somebody would patch this window up
The bow makes fights much easier dash around kite the enemy's lead is fine. Okay
Oh Logan Cunningham voices Hades with four voices ag and skelly. Yeah, I could tell he voices skelly. I could I could hear that
Can you feel pain if he's only bones? Well, he looks like he has some sort of like stuff on him
Again
By the power of who's next like a Daedalus hammer
Is this gonna be
Let me guess
What's that one guy that married Aphrodite?
Enchantments for my weapon. Oh, no, it's just a Daedalus hammer. Okay
I thought it was gonna be called as Daedalus because I know like Daedalus Icarus blah blah blah
I'm talking about. I thought they're just calling whatever one of the what's the guy's name
Their attack fires two shots at my son
Oh, that sounds a sense
Like
I was crazy good too bad. I'm gonna
Whoa
Oh my god
Ouchy, uh, I did it. Yeah, I see more. I did it
If that's just thank you
Thank you. Who's here?
Grimstones
Ah crystals
Oh, what the hell I'm stuck
I like how they can just move through stuff, excuse me
Yeah
Oh I miss
Yeah, yeah
I'm an astrology girl. You can't hurt me
I'm already almost dead what I wouldn't give a say what do these mean?
I
This is hard. This is arrow. I don't know. I'm gonna go to the thing. I don't recognize
Alrighty, all right, don't step on those motherfucking things. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, I missed
I like this one charge the volley. I can't aim that well though. Oh god
No
Ow
Ow, ow, ow
I'm gonna die. No, I just started
No
Oh god
Yeah, yeah, I'm attacking like I have the sword, but I don't
Oh
I'm not good at this
Hmm had to come back for something right quick
Don't talk to me
I probably have to talk to you
I'm embarrassed
What you're back already. Hey, my list says that you barely leave me alone. Hypnos
I didn't feel bad. I'm not good. I'm I'm learning
What this how goes the chains?
Oh, I like they're just chatting. They're chatting about how I died
Skelly what's up, honey showed up shut up
Thank you. Hi Zeus. I didn't mean to press that
We need to get a young man yours isn't by a fair right
That's cool. Uh
Especially because of the lightning bolt
Oh, I like the electric shot
I haven't been dashing a lot. I'm gonna do this one. Is my hair sticking up?
So
Oh
Okay
Oh, okay, then I need to grab my special back. Okay, I see
All right, there's a key over here. That's cool
Okay, I'm learning. Okay, don't step on these fucking things
Uh
Like I found a key cool a key to a weapon nifty
Okay, so I can either talk to Zeus or is there another one?
Like how my dashing is just echoes, okay
Okay, so if I win I get to talk to Zeus again
These ones I need to stay away from
What the hell
That worked
Okay, I kind of ought to lock on so that's fine
Okay, okay
Oh
Oh, that's probably we'll kill him. I probably need that
What's this do I get like ambrosia?
You either talk to Zeus or talk to Zeus
Easy snipe. I'm a sneak bear
Sneaky
Oh god, at least you died from that mostly
You stay away. Oh, yeah, you jump pretty far
Oh, but then yeah, if you hit me you get more damage
I'm just gonna back up
All right, let's see. I don't know how this dashing hit. I don't know
Oh, I can't shoot that. That's not an enemy. Ah, I'll turn to that. Oh, no, not you
Um, I have one health
Yeah
I need to get out of this corner
Oh, I don't know why I did that. I'm so stupid. I didn't mean to step on that
No
It locks onto their hipbox. Okay, that's good to know
Oh blasted spank traps everywhere. Okay
I like how I just talk about how I died
Oh, what do you have to say? So you got steward via spike trap out there, huh?
Oh, okay. I hypnos. I don't think I'm ever gonna talk to you again. Welcome home boy
You're late. That's all right father
I'm asked repeatedly for the construction of a sundial, but every time
Why would you need a sundial if we're underground?
For all our sparring practice, there's no teacher like the real thing
What why you're giving me your codex I can't please I insist
I don't know what this means
Oh
Okay
I like the smug expression that hypnos has on his face
What this what once was a small lounging area within the house of Hades now was sealed off in utter
That's cool. So Chris destroyed the lounge again
Or the aesthetic
Hello
I will get whatever that means
there
My nice whatever animal this is this doesn't look like a bear. It looks like a lion
But it also looks like a lion bear
lion avatar
Hi skelly. What's up pretty quick in old boy. Oh just be sure to use that fancy dash of yours
Yeah, you're right mad instead of standing still
You're right. You should do that. Um
This needs more keys to open
Oh if I equip I get 20 percent more
Should I do that?
Should I do that? Is that a thing I should be doing?
I'll do it
Shut up I'll grab it
Because I get bonus
Okay, but for death's defiance, okay, I don't know what that is but sure
Let's see what I can do with this sword
Attack becomes a big chop. The deal is 90 base damage
I don't know what that
Uh, I don't have any obels so I am going to take this
All tuned up
You can cancel your attack animation with dashes good to know
So let's see what? Yeah. Yeah
Oh, yeah, this is really narrow. Um, I'm trying to think
At my side
Nifty nifty
Oh
I really killed that one over there
Right away
50 I can use this to unlock a weapon
So I can either what does this one mean?
Because this one I I'm assuming I talk to a guy. It's probably Artemis and then this one is what?
Isn't that my symbol? I don't know
Ah
I need a any dash to the dash has a little bit of a cool down
It's like
I got two second cool down
This means money
Money money money
Must be funny
Interest man. Well, do I go here then?
Is money is important should I get monies?
Did I do I need monies at this early stage?
Or would it be worth it to talk to whatever god?
I said because it's eagle
I'm assuming this will be for like cosmetics and stuff for the work whatever
For the contractors
Can't die they die first
You don't hold on to the money if you die
So then how do I get back to the hub if I can use it if I can't use it
I thought I only get back to the hub if I die
Booms are better talk to the god. Okay
I'll probably die
Money is run dependent good to know
Oh, I meant to run away
I'm trying to run but I'm not running pressing the wrong button to run
Ow, I don't like these guys
Yeah
Let's keep spamming that
Hello
Yeah, I was gonna say
I'm like does it all also shoot arrows because the sisters are
Oh, I love her design look at her little owl friends
Thanks Artemis
Oh
Dash strike
Maybe this will be helpful the hunter dash
Although because I already have
Hmm
Innovation money is different as a different currency. Oh, okay
It's the biabilities. Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. Good to know
She's the crit lady
Crit damage
Here
Hmm me me me me me
He me me me me me me. What are you guys's suggestions?
No bad abilities. All right. I'm gonna go with the dash because I feel like I'm gonna try to utilize dash more
The hunt sounds like good company to keep. Why do I have a giant book?
Oh, damn. I love all the fucking art in this game
Oh
Well, I would have done option one had I known
Okay, that actually cancels it out
Ow
Oh
I hate these things
Oh, I walk I keep thinking that's an enemy, but it's the thing
Okay
Yeah, I gotta learn how things stack on each other
One with my sword chop would have been good. Okay
Ouch. All right
Again, there are no bad options. This is not the cash for this. What even lied to you
Oh, what's up?
Are you just gonna tell me how I die each time such a dignity for my own kin shut up dad. I'm it's not a face
Achilles, is it really true that Cerberus ripped the lounge up right after I left?
I only wish you could have seen it lad
The place looked like a vineyard after typhoon. Your lord father was livid
But he never gets so angry with the doll. No, I wonder what became Medusa
She's always worried father's going to fire her even without something like that. Is that Medusa?
Where's my dog
Cerberus must be asleep somewhere. Maybe this is my room. Well, that was quick
You'd like that, wouldn't you?
Lucky, I've got other family be careful whom you give your trust
My brother's frolic on Olympus
Oh
What the heck who is that
Is that Medusa's head
I uh just wanted to say don't bother picking up my room today
I'm headed out for a while. She's a cleaning lady
Oh my god, I love her voice
What
She just flew up to nowhere
Hemnos is the biggest back seating little brother
I like Medusa. Dusa is fun to speak
I I um
I have to clean the rafters
Hello
Oh
Why do you look so upset
A commemorative board adorns one of the stoic walls within the lounging area
Celebrating it won't ever see my face up on that wall. I who is that?
I want to know who that is on the wall for employee of the month
And he adjusts my booty cheek is getting sore
What are these things on the ground are they supposed to be chairs
These are so weird. I just clipped through them greetings chef
Can I ask you for food?
Look at these little guys. I like how they disappear when I walk with them. Does the chef disappear? No, the chef is solid
What about you you disappear?
Can I steal some fish and bread
This game is so nice relaxed no time to rest. Oh, I'm all fuck you then never mind
I like how there's a freaking lounge
Hi though your journeys take you elsewhere
Thanks grandma
That's Fred
Oh it's Cerberus's hair. Oh
So I've already expected Cerberus to be in my room like sleeping on my bed or something. Um
I don't think I have anything. Yeah, I only have two death defines
Oh, okay
That's good to know. Yeah, I'll save for that
Oh
How's it going? What's up skelly? Hey pal watch where you throw those bloodstone things at yours you drop them
You go pick them up. You understand
I'm just saying generally from the midsection since
Okay, that makes sense
I'm gonna grab this again. I need my bow
All flashing the power shot
Oh
What is release
That's not really flashing
Release while flat what is while flashing mean
Cerberus should say like the cats
Uh
Sorry
When zag flashes white
Oh, oh, it's a timing thing
Gotcha, okay. I'm not gonna ever time that properly
Again
Again sound
Dionysus question mark. Is that a ball of wine? What the heck is this? I can't even tell what the symbol is
People having a good time. Well, sure then
Hey, yo
Oh my god, he's gorgeous
You've been saving you a spot. Let me see what I can do. I love this design the purple
It's like I don't must remind me of like male Azura because of the purple
Oh, my character designs are so gorgeous
Wow, look at the grapes. Oh my god
He is like a little pine cone staff
That's so cool
I
Pack inflicts hangover what is a hangover
Is that like a stun like they get like
Like some keeps taking down. Oh, okay stacks. So it's almost like poison
This seems like it's a airy aoe
We call the pantheon for a reason she bx Dionysus fan fix it coming. No, no
It's a debuff. Yeah
Drunken strike I just turned into broccoli
I can't wait to see
More characters
I'm like very excited because everybody's gorgeous and just the art is so beautifully drawn
Yes, yeah, I was at the beginning of the stream I was reading that they're almost essentially the same person
They're like two sides at the same point. Um
I really honestly Zag's
design
Really interests me because I'm wondering what's going up with this heterochromia
I wonder if that's like a stylistic choice or has some purpose or meaning to it
I didn't see what color I don't think Dionysus like had a true eye color in this art
Because it would be cool if they gave like Dionysus like the same
Thing but swapped to just acknowledge that connection
I think you go for the three I was thinking about going for the three
But press
Yeah for the
Okay
I'll take this one leave it to the god of wine to lighten things up around here. I want to see it
What the heck
Oh
That one is good. Oh shit
Nice interesting
Smack the debuff in a special for AoE damage over time option
Aries boons or his damage doesn't get simpler. Yeah
I think nix's designs is my nix nix's design is my favorite. I can't see this enemy past my phone
Are you get that back
Yeah
Oh, I like this can I have it back? Oh, oh, this is so neat. Okay. I actually like this attack. Yeah, yeah
Kobe
Over there
It's right next to me. Oh, am I saying over there? Do I get more of these? I probably do
cool
Oh, let's go talk to Poseidon. Well, I figured that out. Thanks. Not thanks to you, dude. Um
I need a volley
I need a dash more dash strike. Oh fuck
Okay, I need to run around and go back and get that
Um
That's better. Let's see if I can gather them up in a circle. Yeah, that works. They're all close
Yeah, oh, what the hell I'm not paying attention. I forgot that was gonna run out
Crashing waves a trident
Uncle number two. It's got to be
Then in the name of Hades
Olympus I accept this message
Oh
His hair is so fluid
Dude his beard is sick
I love I just I have no words. I love his design his hair looks like
And I love his the seahorse headdress and little pearls
Oh my god, that's so cool. I'm sorry. I'm just so happy to be here
Everybody's so beautiful
I want to see more women
I'm getting I'm getting inspiration to be a Greek goddess for my 3.0
Oh, that'd be the goddess of
Oh
I'm also
I don't have any of that I will do this one
Looks like I caught a big one the power of the seas should be of help. Yeah, baby. Yeah
In Greek mythology Poseidon is the biggest man who are in a show. What are you talking about? That's Zeus
Zeus is a man whore
In my opinion
Zeus just great juice boxes people a lot actually
Yeah
What oh I just I can put it away interesting
Fascinating well come a little closer then
Oh
I
Like area of attack stuff
Thank you
I wish this was just fly back to me at the end of the level. Okay. Whoo. So we got
pomegranates. I'm assuming that's Persephone. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Let's talk to our mom
He has the most children. I didn't know that goddess of ropes and rabbits
Oh be a bun goddess
I could be like one of Aphrodite's daughters because like, um, I think in like, uh,
What is it? What mythology mythology?
Ishtar
Is like
She's like I forget which version but she's she's not Aramaic. It's not Hebrew
I forget but she her symbols. That's where uh, Easter comes from her symbols are the agon or rabbit
and they just mix the
Spring equinox and Easter so that the Christians would be happy
Maybe I could be like her
Because she has a fertility goddess as well and then me and Azur can be fertility goddesses together
Bro, this game is making me want
This game is making me want, uh
Want that
It's like, what the freak are these? What is this?
What is that?
Oh god, why are they throwing mines?
Oh god, I'm in the range
Oh god, geez there's so many how the oh, this is probably where the dash comes in
How do you throw them so far?
Oh
How do I shoot again? I keep doing the volley instead of anything else
What the hell
A palm of power
Good enough to eat
Interesting, um
Oh, so my festive fog gets stronger
Hmm
First 10 seconds and encounters that also helps
Hmm me me me me me these are both good
Sheebie daughter of Aphrodite
No, you have to put like an e in my name somewhere
Like she bae
To make it sound Greek
Goddess of domination seduction and oh see that works. It works. It works
Was an afro birth some seafoam. Yes
I
From Uranus's balls
Palms grant more power the boons you get that's good to know damages to mobs the yellow health bar do not carry to the
I don't know what that means
You're describing things. I don't know the name of I mean they don't understand
Any meanie money mo catch a tiger by the toe if he hollows, then I'll go well this one is more
This one's more long term. This is only the first 10 seconds, but doesn't it last 10 seconds almost a century? Oh
For every five seconds
Hmm, I'm gonna go at this one. They must have lots of these upon Olympus
Not a poem
Oh, I'm gonna go get another one. Hello
What the heck oh, oh love that lob that shit. Oh perfect
Need a back
Oh god
Oh
I need to get them all in one spot
Yes, that worked out
I need this one, I guess is the host one so that makes sense. Oh my god, I can't get out
Now once you guys walk over here, how about that?
Okay, um, let me get this back
Oh god, oh, I feel that the wrong way. Okay, it doesn't matter
There we go cool and then we press that
Okay
The power of Olympus, so yeah, now I can just do that one better blessing
Let me grab. I wonder if I leave the room when I would just not have it still alive
Not for long
Who wins in a torque off your LeBron James LeBron James
Uh, okay, I wish I could have a little bit more hail
But it is what it is
Why am I
Glowing
Oh, no, I knew that was gonna stack immediately
They also they have such a long range that was good though. That was a good run
The jam comes back to me father. Well
All right, I like AoE stuff. That's my favorite
I don't even want to talk to you. Can I talk to you? Oh, I can listen to you both
I like how he has flowers come out from him. Are they poppies because that would be funny
I like how they put the weirdest pitch on her
Like what why did they
Why did they make her voice like that? I like it. Don't get me wrong
But the voice changer maybe the voice changer is supposed to be obvious
Honestly, I feel like Dusa is voiced by hypnos the same person
Get on it hypnos
I don't
Be quiet dad. I was wondering Achilles
Any news of Orpheus of late? I've not that I believe he is
Your father he was not too pleased with him last time I saw him here
I hope so too or Orpheus if you do see him ten of my said hi
When his lady friend and his lady love, um
What's over here? What's that? It's locked
Oh
If I don't pet your other heads don't bite my arm off
I love you. How you holding up boy eating well lately
Each terrifying more of the infernal watchdog service responds affirmatively one after the next
It's always funny to me when animals and games like no english, but they can't speak it
Hey, they're just like the language
They're just like there's like bark
Hi dad. I see you've decided to come home
Changed your mind yet. I definitely
We're looking for more pain and suffering
Dusa is like a little
I was going to say something but there's a right. Hi serenity. Hi raiders. Hello
Hi
I hope you had a good stream welcome in my name is she be caught in mom if you don't know who I am
I am your favorite girl failure dom and natrix
And i'm playing hades right now. I hope you were enjoying um, whatever serenity he was streaming
I've never played hades before so far. I love it
sweetie bun raid
He he he welcome welcome. It's really good. I love the art. Oh my gosh. I love the art so much in this game
The voice acting is wonderful
It's so good
You keep telling yourself that boy
But mark you my words
Sooner or later this life that you have chosen for yourself shall teach you. I was right double bunny
It's two bunnies in one room. What could happen good talk. How was your stream serenity?
I
Got that what is going on in here? It's popping
Hey, I know you
What the heck I don't know what those are the lounging area within the house of hades is a dismal place to be
What
I
It's better than nothing
Can I get some food?
Can I get a waffle? Can I please get a waffle? Can I please?
Get a waffle
All right
Why is this stuff this is so cool
So much stuff
I want to know who that person is with a big gold star
Like some minecraft
Minecraft
We're back in the mine got my pickaxe swinging from side to side side side to side
I feel like a zombie come I ever had a song come goes
Uh i'm 14. I still have enough it
I'm gonna save up for that thing you guys recommended
I
Guess the gods when it yeah
But they could eat
Immortal food, you know, you know something boy. Oh, I think you could do a real number on one of these columns
Holding up this place and bring the whole thing down and just a few swipes boom boom boom
Yeah, I realized oh he has a gold coin in his mouth
Interesting. I wonder how that's like related to
Sharon
My father's finely crafted architecture every chance I get that I can do for sure
Oh, that has a bonus, but I can't use it. Oh wait, can I use it open up?
You just shield of chaos. Oh your power
What is this? Hey nice bash
Holy crap. Oh, oh my god. I'm freaking captain america
And this is an auto lock on on him though. Oh, I moved him
You
Interesting let's try it
Bye bye bye one more time shield is neat
This is america's ass
Oh Poseidon hey
What's up daddy? Oh, I just love his sign so much
We've been holding back one of our greatest gifts to see
Oh, what's this? Oh, shit call makes you surge in a photo on pervit. What?
What?
I get impervious press r2 for olympians aid
One stock of my god gauge or four stocks. What?
The wrath of Poseidon at my back and call. Oh
What the heck
Oh my god
He's dead. He's dead. I think he died. He's gone that one
I can get some jewels
Call is alt. Oh, it's an alt. Oh, okay. That makes sense
After america, but freaky
Let's get freaky with it. How do I throw stuff?
Oh
Yeah, oh no, I hate these guys
Yeah
Yeah, yeah
Oh, yeah, maybe I shouldn't step on that did it block me
I
Yeah
Oh, I walked into that. Yeah. Yeah
I'll set I get some money
I
Large listen Tina
Cool
Give me the monies
I'll hang on to these. I don't know what they do. What is this?
Where to I like this one. I think this is Athena, isn't it?
Oh
Is that like drain him or something
I keep forgetting what does what
All right. Wow
Oh
Oh, no
Yeah
Cool
Her symbol is so weird
Oh, she blinked look at her. I didn't notice her little owl
I'm staring at her majesty
She is
Utterly glowing. I did not listen to a word. You just said oh, it's because of your shield. That makes more sense
Hmm I'm learning lore your attack is stronger
I
Guess because this one
Your cast
I need to sit up
Captain shabby leader of the new Avengers the dog
Forget the punisher. I'm the dominator
Let the kill him to get it back and the gem is on them. Oh, okay interesting. All right. I'm gonna try this because I like aoe stuff
Um, so we get this or that
So that like I haven't any time I do one of these I haven't gotten it yet, but I would rather get one of these
Whoa, excuse me
Let's try it
What the hell
Holy crap
I'm op. Yeah, you see he had an exclamation point because he was running away
Oh, I can literally just spam this the entire time
This is nice. This is very nice
Trying to hide behind this fucking pillar
Oh
Imagine if I had more of these. Oh my god. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
I need to kill the main head. Oh stop it stop
There we go
We'll go
E do be do be do dee dee be do
I like this game. I like this game a lot
What the hell is that?
What is that locked?
Huh weird
Oh dammit
Why are you so strong for no reason?
I don't like those guys. These are my least least favorite guys
I
Need a sip of my drink
Just have to try again
I want to see zag with red hair now because I think he'd look good with red hair
Shut up Hypnos. I'm not talking to you. What Achilles?
Where are you? Where for art thou Achilles?
Hmm
Hi dad
Father everybody's dead
Everybody's dead
Okay
What's that there something from the fates
Uh
Face prop I don't know what that means. I haven't seen anything happening with the fates
I
Can make the seating more luxurious I can't tell which is which oh pool
Okay
Okay, I don't really care about any of that stuff. Um, I probably only care about like the workbench whatever
That's my dog's hair everywhere
Hi charlie. Thank you for the soup, but it's your birthday. Oh my gosh. Happy birthday to you
Happy birthday to you
Happy birthday dear charlie
Happy birthday
to you
Oh, he's happy. Oh, he's gone
I hope you had a good birthday
I uh, I hope you're having a nice day. She's so cute. I love her so much. I don't want to share any more here, highness
And there she goes again. Oh come back. I don't I wouldn't expect her Medusa's character to be like so cutesy
Do you read faster than they speak? Uh, I do read faster than they speak even then I I still like, um
I still
Slow it down and I wait a moment before I go move on. I'm a very fast reader
Um, I'm gonna wait. I want the death defiance. I have four more
How's it going? Hi scaly. What's up? I suppose I can talk you into fighting back this time
Not a chance boy. Oh, I'm paid to take it. Not who's paying you
Okay, give it to you. What does that even mean?
I would like more my blade
But you couldn't hit me with that pal
You just are a weirdo
Novus
Oh
You says the best I like I just I like do so me strength. I like how she's called do so not Medusa
They kind of wanted to differentiate her. Oh wait. I get the symbol. Oh damn Poseidon you just
Gave me all the love
My crusty elder brother
Um
Your dash damages foes in an area or again, I like my cast stuff. I like my cast oily stuff
I might have the sea
Wow, okay, god. Oh my god. Uh, I think they're dead
Come here
Can't quite see what's going on
Oh
Oh, you're like close to death. I want to make sure I get something to boost that
Want to step on that
These fucking guys
Oh my god, I can't even is he stuck on something he's literally just stuck over there
Oh my god, they're all exploding now
He was stuck on the rock and couldn't move out from this corner
Okay, so we got health or monies
Oh
I'm gonna I don't really need health, but so I guess I'll go monies. Although I don't really need the monies
I'm a caster. What's a caster?
Out out
Ah, oh my god, there's so many
I don't know what caster means
I'll take it
That's a lot of money
Okay, so I can get gems or more this stuff that's to upgrade the thingy. That's uh, I rather focus on this for now
Sadly won't be able to use the special too much until you get more shards
You can hit the projectiles with your sword if you want to oh
Oh
Wait for the witches
Can I can I hit the
Witches projectiles whose projectiles can I hit?
If she be was a great goddess
She she a b no no you have to put that the a before the e
Daughter of Aphrodite goddess of domination seduction pleasure and desire major symbols include cotton ropes and rabbits
Oh
I need to take a screenshot of that
My attacks are strong now for some reason because I'm getting good. No, that's not true
Oh god, oh god
Oh god, Jesus Christ
Oh, no, oh, I doubt that
Oh
Wait, is this Aphrodite
What then the Daedalus hammer it's fine. Let's talk to her
Yeah
Oh
What the freak I shouldn't have thrown that then
How do I break armor? Oh, this is gonna take longer
I kind of had a wish I had the arrows for this
Ow
Oh
Yeah
I thought I would have stunned mum
I've he's like fixing his hair. He's like I must be a mess. Oh, let me fix my hair
Ah
Let this specimen and so I've decided I shall aid you for the moment. Are you interested?
Pretty lady pretty lady
She's naked. Oh, she is legit naked literally her hair is just covering her. Oh my god
I love how her hair curls look like upside down hearts
And I just got a shiver
Special deals more damage
I
Damage nearby flows if you take damage was ready for three. I'll do the heart
Interested and the power to break hearts
Sure, I don't see why not. I mean like you're interested in me like you want to go on a date like
Aphrodite you you want some I know you want some
You want some of this
You want some of that
Are you thinking about you know, what is this? Oh, it's a shot. Oh
Cool
Hi, Charlie. Thank you for the super speaking of pre gods. Have you had I heard you have a collab coming up?
Who told you that?
I am collabing with mythos
Ah
The mythos girls. Um, well, I'm a mercy. Uh, we're like, hey, you want to do mario party and I was like
Yeah
Remind if I do so I can't wait to hang out with them hanging out with Poseidon and Apollo
It's really cool
She's the goddess of starting your stuff
Aphrodite and Hades related uh technically since
Hades
since it's
I know Aphrodite was born from the sea
But
I forget I Poseidon not Poseidon. Um
Zeus does have some all the gods related don't even think about it
My special has more damage
I could buy all of these
Should come in useful
Might as well since I have enough monies
I
Yeah, it is Hades would be her uncle
I wonder if Sharon actually shows up
I'll get one of these
Oh
Oh, shit, what the hell is happening? Oh my god
That was hard
I believe you're collabing with real greek gods. I know it's really cool
Poseidon told me
Oh, that's cool
And reveal her. Oh, she oh, that's so cool
Yeah, I can't wait. It's so funny. Um back when I was rena. I did a I was telling Poseidon this I did a watch along of
Their reviews again, I was like a small indie so it's not like anybody
It wasn't like a sponsored thing or anything
And I really love Poseidon's design and I loved her
Visual novel debut thing
And I remember pretending to respond to like
Her questions
It was goofy. It was funny. So it's really cool full circle that actually gets to hang out with her. I'm very I feel very lucky
um
I'm very excited to like branch out and hang out with girls on their corpos
And like I already hung out with you may plus and we're hanging out with them again, and I'm really happy
I'm happy. I'm making more friends
Cheers
Rude, where's my dog?
Yes, that's how fast I read I just look at it and it's red
Hey, what's up?
Hell as you once did Achilles though doubtless many of the shades who stand against me first arrived in Tartarus because
that's funny
It's weird because Achilles looks like an old band from far away, but
I can't really tell let's see this face. I feel like this is like a teleportation thing
um
Where's my dog?
I
Enhancement some part are artifact ever shifting on the road
Okay, you ever shifting chambers of the underworld ought to be a little livelier with this
You are distracting me. I'm not doing anything dad. Chill out
Oh, I can get rid of the clumps of fur. That's funny
I
Was repair so there's repair and decor
Okay
Oh, hey grandma's back
Probably get rid of Cerberus's hair
Hello
Hello this guide you child
I like how her skulls on her chest look like really bashful and embarrassed
Are you learning about the gospel truth? Yes, I am
Emi plus cloud was wrong. That was so much fun. Oh my god. I haven't laughed that hard in such a long time
It was so fun
Voice actors work hard, I agree. They really do they do such a good job
I want to be I seriously it's literally my dream to voice act in a game like this. That'd be so awesome
Going from zero to hero in no time flat
You want her to do dog things very busy stuff there
Thank you next. How you doing Toma
My hands are cold. My circulation's been bad. My shoulders been flaring up a lot
And I
Had to lift some boxes and so I strained it even more
And it was really hard to lift and so but thankfully the thing that lets me
drag stuff around the little
Uh beach cart or buggy thing came in so I was able to bring my trash down
But of course it was heavy and I had to bring it upstairs first
That hurt
Oh, let's do what's greater reflex. Oh
Um
Oh
How's it going? Hi, if you don't know who I am I actually be cottonbump your favorite girl failure dumb extraordinaire
um
I'll spit on you hit to talk to her
I hope you caught that in your mouth. Um, we're playing Hades. It's my first time playing. I really like it so far
I didn't know how much I enjoy roguelikes ever since I played call the lamb. I love this one. I hope you guys had fun
in tempestream
You should talk to Poseidon's use some VA experience. She likes to give advice
I definitely will talk to her about that. I'm great. I'm sipping ice coffee and reaching about wish again
I still have to watch that movie
I really want to watch it. Oh temple. Let me let me let me give you a little
The hot girl wrench as they call it
Hot girl wrench people keep talking and I can't catch up to your name
Whoa, where'd my game go?
Where'd my OBS go? Everything's ruined. It's just kidding
Ah, my arm hurts. It hurts to flux my reef my little
Fingies
I've played pegglin. I love roguelikes and she tried Hades soon. I
I've never heard of that one. What's that one about?
You can rage together. Yeah, we can do a watch along with that. I heard I I remember seeing some stuff that I just like doesn't make any
sense whatsoever
Because it's like it's like the villain actually is more
Understandable than like the main character is what I've heard
Hot girl wrench. Yeah, you get the hot girl wrench
Teiglin is very cool. I'll have to look at that one. I didn't know how much I like roguelikes, but I do. I like them a lot
Oh and five keys I can how many keys do I have?
How many keys do I have?
No, she would tell me
Need more keys
Need more keys all set cool. Okay
It's like peggle, but a roguelike. Oh, that sounds good. I can't unlock this don't have enough keys. I want the pitchfork
Yay
All right
I like I like
That yes, I am shut up. Um, I wonder what else shows up here. I wonder if I eventually get more
What's that?
The courtyard of the house of Hades is it's not that orderly really
It's not I like how like lackadaisical he sounds
Let's look at this beautiful view
This will all that the way to the surface
Like how it's running rivers of blood how fast is this like how far away is the surface?
Like a hundred chambers. I bet it's something ridiculous that I'm never gonna get to
One more time. No
Poseidon come on. Let's go. Oh
Aries
This one was bound to show up. I guess
Those areas look like spirit in you there. I have to say that's such a cool most intriguing
Then you have no surprise to be honest. I'm very surprised with the amount and tell me all about of poc
That there is in this game
It's very cool
But it's also just like they're also like very uniquely colored
It's very like there's different shades because like a theme is a little bit more grayish purple and he's like
more of a
Yeah, red undertone brown
It's very that I really like the diversity in their designs and they all are very true
to like their lore the
The the artist really took
lots of care
and um
In designing uh
These characters. I really really really like it. Also, uh, the helmet thing it reminds me. Oh
What is it?
Slade from
From teen titans because a little thing on their thing
Or like when robin this mini slade or whatever the heck
Your attack inflicts doom
I
This is so cool
Oh my god, I love the art. I'm just sharing a tag holding up Ares little thing. I'm a bobber
Oh my god, it's freddy that game of Hades is epic intense and interesting. It really is you're so right freddy
Oh
It takes the first damage
Huh
So if I run
It'll leave something behind me
This one is is rare though. I might go with the rare one
Hmm
Yeah, let's try it the war is on
Oh
Ow, I'm already getting hurt
I feel like I should have got a different one
So
Music is so good
Gemstones sick
I can talk to Ares again. I kind of want to keep stacking Ares's stuff because that would be cool
Ah
Nice, what is that?
Oh, okay, it's like a little bomb thing
Interesting interesting. I bet if I hit it
Oh, I bet it would have damaged him if it was closer
I
Yeah, I do think I like being having a ranged weapon
He did the music for the game
Damn, that's cool
My cast ends up lay
Oh, I can just have them all
Oh, this is a hard choice these are very good
Ares is cracked. Yeah, that's why I was like, let me pick Ares again
I feel like this would be good because this isn't
This will be an aoe
Not really
Maybe I don't know
Which one do you guys think I'm gonna take a sip of my drinky pool
Too is pretty good for shred. Yeah
Blade rift is fun. Let's try it. I want to see what it looks like
Is that all you got to say about that violence? Is there another room? Okay, it looks like it's just this one
Violence
Oh
Nifty, okay
It's very slow though. I have to cast it very close. All right
Now I hate these guys
Where the fuck did you come from? Oh bounces back and forth
Oh
I might die at this one
Yeah, I died at this one
I like that it comes back to me
Hmm
I can get moneys or I can get moneys. I was hoping I would get something other than moneys
Oh, they jump so far
Oh
The guards should fetch me something
Does it fetch me something do is there a little oh usually would sit over here, but it's not there. Uh, okay
If I fight fat men I might lose
This is a good follow-up because then I can throw this and then I can just be like try to get that sweet spot and then
Just keep shooting
Okay, they don't get that far I can't see what I'm shooting at
out
I'm stuck I'm stuck
Yeah, me really cornered there because I couldn't get out of there
All right, oh my kid can I drop that oopsies?
Who is this is that's a person
What does that mean? So this is Poseidon and he'll give me some really good boost. I can see
That I'm also at 10. What does this mean?
I don't know that means
You have met Aries the god of war lightning strikes
Very intense. Oh, this is that guitar
Hmm
That's a shot. Oh, okay, then I'm just gonna go here. I don't really care about the shop that much
Oh
What the hell are these? Oh my god
Oh, this is gonna be hard
So
Oh, does their stuff build back up
Oh
Oh, it's stupid fucking pillars in the way
Is he stuck
All right
It's by understanding you've been blessed already by one of my other nephews Aries
As you can see not all of us are cut for the same cloth
And thank the fates for that
Oh, yeah, okay
I think the dash would be good
But this is good
No good
I can only use that once though. I would prefer the title dash
Who felt that? Oh, yeah, that's good
She's cracked not even true
Let's come at even
Oh, baby, see I I'm so glad I got that dash
Who should I give this to
A me is there anybody else?
Okay
That's the farthest I've come the aoe madam is so humble
All right
Actually, maybe if I can get them
Aoe's just go to in this game
So
This is good choke point. I'm gonna kill this guy first
Oh, damn it
Oh, holy shit, okay, cool
I love the dash the dash is so good
Uh, should I get a key I'm gonna work on getting more of these
Dad survive for 45 seconds
Oh
Oh, the dash is goaded. Oh, I couldn't even shoot in here. Oh
Almost there
I
Literally just gonna dash a shit ton no for the best enough there we go
Okay, I got money it's fine
Sorry, I'm like so locked in I'm like this is fun
Oh, I love this
These are cool because I can just dash through them and they die instantly
And then I can also
Grab that back
Oh
I keep walking into those
Hmm
I'll get a key because last time
This game is funny
Oh god, oh, oh, I'm not gonna lose one
So
Oh, yeah, this is very hard
Oh look ahead
Oh
Bro this I need to any time I get a dash I'm getting a dash
There's no way I'm getting I'm not getting a dash
Uh, that's the bank and then I rather oh, there's nothing
Okay, what does this do
I don't sleigh foes quickly
I don't know what I'm doing
Oh
This is fun, okay
Cool cool cool cool cool cool cool cool
Nifty nifty
Oh your tack fire
Three shots and spread pattern
Hades every day next week. No, we're gonna replay some Elden Ring
I'm kind of wishing I waited to make my schedule because I would have thrown Haiti on the list
Hades on the list
Our time for our shoot by said three shots and spread pattern
I
Like the range
This is pretty much my volley, but it's
A little bit stronger
This will chain it
I would prefer the volley
Because I don't know if I'll have three foes around me. So I don't know if there's
A point
Not to make it. No, but I don't think my manager appreciate me redoing my time schedule. What is that?
Beyond the present chamber lies the outermost perimeter of Tartarus
Promising terrifying dangers far beyond the underworld princess reckoning
Okay, so I think I'm reckoned quite a bit. I'm assuming I'm getting out of Tartarus if I try if I go this one
Okay
Get ready to schmoove. All right, I thought so
Well, this is awkward
Pulse agris not one step further. Oh, she is hot
Oh my god
Mommy, sorry mommy and she has a whip
Sorry, I'm literally just like dumbfounded right now. I can't I don't have anything to say
I don't have anything to say. I'm just I'm just staring at her majesty
She's a cute little nose ring going on. She's amazingly painted pink nails
I just
I may if she's a fury
Oh my god
I want her
I want to furiously
Eat her out
It's the employee of the mom come on make it. Haven't we had more than enough of each other by now besides don't you have some place else to be
Your father sent me all and all I'd rather be on your bad side than his
Now you can turn back like a good little oh, I love her voice. Oh my god
What'll it be?
She's like whisper talking
How don't it be?
Your father sent me all in all I'd rather be on your bad side than his
Now you can turn back a little peek a little good. I can't talk but yeah, you get it
I'll have to go with the painful way
A man after my own heart a man after my own heart
Ma'am
I
How
How did oh fuck I walked into that
Ah, I'm so stupid walking into these don't think it's wrong with me
Oh
Oh, she is really high health
Oh god, oh god. Oh shit. Oh god. Oh shit fuck
Oh
Hell half no fury a little woman scorned
Oh, oh god, I can dash and kind of be impervious for a bit
I wish I had a super
Oh
I'm like scared to get near her
I'm not even worried about the fucking smaller dudes
Oh
Rutches of Tartarus come in
Oh, I'm so stupid
Where is she
Oh fuck
Oh
Shit
Damn
I got I got her what like halfway
That was pretty good. That was pretty good
I'm give that to a friend
No, I'm not giving that to you. That's for sure
Um, hey, hi, can I give it to my dad? I give it to my dog
I can give it to nicks
I can give it. Can I give it to oh my god, I can give it to her. Um
Frick there's a lot of people I can give this to this is
Uh, I probably shouldn't give it to the dog, but although I really want to I'm gonna give it to nicks
Nicks is my favorite
Um nicks you've done so much for me, you know, your father does not like it when nectar is doled out on the premises giving her drugs
However
I'm very grateful next. What's a black shell?
Oh cool
Oh interesting is this where the romance I just give them gifts
Really good for the first try. Thank you. Thank you
You have met most of your olympian relatives by now child
They all still think I'm headed to join them on olympus. That's why they're helping me
Oh, but what am I doing instead? They are helping you because you are family
Interesting it's getting complicated pretty fast
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm
Do I have another one? Oh, I have two to give. I'm gonna talk to you first
Turns out that I may be stopping back from time to time like this, but please don't bother picking up my room
I love her so much
Like how my room is just there like it's there's the snow leading to other people's rooms
Ah, what's up hypnos?
Beautiful um anyway, I hope the fates are nicer to you next time. Oh, do you have a crush? Do you have a crush hypnos?
Achilles have you ever run across the shade of Daedalus in all your time?
I found some of his legendary hammers out there, but no sign of him
I've never met him no your father keeps him fully occupied with building out his underworld
Indeed I have
Hmm. I might give it to I think I'm gonna give it to Achilles
Hey Achilles look this he's been helpful, but here
Equip them in the ruppins area. Okay
This really is for me
You beat me to it then. Oh
Okay Achilles, are we gonna have a bromance? I'm down. I'm down to have a bromance with you Achilles
You know Achilles, thanks so much. They're kind of cute
I know I call you sir, but you can call me sir in the bedroom if you ever want to
Jesus shroud has run up and smile and run away
Through reminiscable characters wonder which will go through four first
It's kind of weird because I'm all related to them. So my cat's attacking my feet again. What's up, dad?
He's back already Cerberus. Hey, I almost beat Megara Megara
Hi Fia, what are you doing?
You're looking for pets? Oh
I'm sorry. He disturbed your rest again Cerberus. What are you talking about job?
At the the dog loves me
Not everybody knows exactly how to give you pets and live to tell them right boy. Can I pet the other heads?
Is that a thing because they always just come up on the side. Can I pet the other heads?
Here boy, just as long as one of your three heads enjoys these pets. Okay
What I can't pet my dog
I got that dog in me. I just want to pet my dog. All right, uh, let's go in here
And
Where could I equip stuff?
So I have 30
Might as well do that. All right, I'm ready
Because I saw that where was that my cat is scratching in the litter box
It's over here
No
This one had the others in bite yikes
If you flirt with hypnos, do you technically flirt with Thanatos too?
Well, Thanatos is death
He's sleep
Are you flirting with sleep and death?
Who is he talking to?
Oh, he's oh this was
Can you not get into the underworld this is interesting next
This is such a cute cool not cute, but it's a cool little thing
In the weapons area after the bedroom. Oh, that's right. You're right
I want to kind of watch like how his beard is a symbol and the symbol also
Is the pitchfork. What is he denying people doing like what is happening here?
This guy has a little poop on his head
Oh, he's blushing. So what? Oh
What's the what's the story here
Oh, I want to see the poop guy go
What are they claiming? I don't know what's happening. I just want to watch it though. Oh, he's also shy
Can I enter to Elysium?
Oh
Poop guy went in. Yay. Good for him. Oh, I can walk through all of them. That's so funny
Okay, anyways, so that one wasn't too happy about it
Good for good for poop head
He's to have office hours for petitions
Oh, he's like, please talk to me
What was that? What was that tick-tock noise?
You act as though this guard mode is some sort of lever
I can simply switch at will if ever I wish to unlock my latent strength there, mate
Damn zag is like really beautiful. His bone structure is
All like is the world. Um, okay, uh
Got something new to try
So I can but I take 10% from the back
How many can I quit? Oh
Cool. All right, so I should probably give stuff to the other characters as well
Just so that I can
Get more stuff
Cool
Um, I'm gonna keep the bow. I'm not really worried about that right now
Hi, rena. Wait, who are you?
Who are you? Who just hopped on my desk? Oh, you're boomy. What the heck? I can't see right now. It's dark
You can sit in the bed. You can't go anywhere else
Oh
Like this court system
I
Skeleton sounds like chief Wimbly from Simpsons. Oh, yeah, you're right. Jimmy's taking 10 more percent damage from the back
You pick one
I pick one. Okay, then I'm gonna pick the shawl then
My keepsakes
Oh
I
Wish you guys could see the faces that please make takes when he's pet because he just looks drunk and high and his mouth opens
Like his mouth is open right now
And he's just putting put on the head and he's
This is funny. I don't know why he does that. He always opens his mouth just like a few days
Oh boom, we don't leave I want to take a picture for everybody
Hold on. Okay, stay right there. Stay right there
I'm gonna take a video
Wait, boomy, lift up your face
Please look up here
Oh my god, there's Fia. Oh, this isn't working. You guys are not good. What is happening? Stop hitting each other
I wanted to
Why are you clawing my chair?
Ma'am
It was trying to oh, okay. You guys are just gonna fight. That's fine
He likes his rubies
Like just imagine like, you know when you like mush a cat's face
That's what I do to boomy because boomy doesn't like his
Uh body pet. He doesn't like like back scratchies or tummy scratchies or anything
He only likes his head and his chin scratched and sometimes his chin
And he may always makes I don't know where he got this from but he just makes a funny face
When he gets his head pat
Oh, you're doing it again now that I put my phone away
I
Suggested us take whichever weapon is 20% in the early game soon like all weapons quickly. Oh, okay
I realize I've just been ignoring keys. I need to track down mochathonic keys. Uh, I only have one
I've been I need to get more keys. Um, I'll get this one. No, but I like the bow. I'm shaving bow
Like how I want to play
Because I'm better with bow
I'm a bow user
All right areas Poseidon
Hermes
A bat wing it looks more like a bird wing, but okay
It's batman batman picked up
He's like the sunset
Places to be
I'm surprised I didn't say like
Messenger of the gods. They just put god of swiftness
Oh, and he has that little staff thing that I can't remember the name of that's such a
I love his scarf. He literally looks like a sunset
Like a little phoenix like he's fiery
His little bag. There's a frog in his bag
I love it
That's so cool
But probably not gonna be relevant blows around the fastest weapons to clear the game with specifically one of the blows
Okay, is that a batman my friend? So you got that frog in him
So I can be faster I can dodge automatically after I'm sturdy
This would be cool if they could get that dash from Poseidon again
My attack is faster. I kind of want the hyper sprint appreciate the lift lord. Hermes. Oh, oh, yeah, that's cool
I like that
He's a swifty I would be too
Oh, okay, is that a chimera?
Okay
I got the timing for that right now I get the timing for it
Yeah, that's not that's not hard to do
Aw health is there another one? I want to get another boon. This might not be a good run at this rate. Oh, I love the little wee
So if you do 10 floors, that's when you hit the boss, right? Where am I?
Ow
I hate these things
See this would be great for an aoe right now
Looks like I just have to keep running around I have to kill these fucking uh
Ow
Ow, what the hell
I'm trying to attack and I can't
Because I know they're not gonna stop unless I kill them
This is not a good run now
Need to press on that ought to keep me going for a bit
I
Know I'm sorry into that
Now oh I hate these things
I
Nice all right, let's chat with Artemis
Was good because that defines always give half of HP some more HP. Oh, okay
Kind of want them to come closer to me
So I don't have to worry about them rushing me
Oh god, yeah should have dashed. I don't know why I'm not dashing
Lady Artemis oh I can gift to her
Lady Artemis, I hope that you'll accept this offering for all your kindness and support
Hey, thank you for this really and I've just the thing to offer in return. Oh, she's so cute. It's just a gift, okay?
She's just like it's just a gift. Don't even think about it. Okay. It's nothing bad. Whatever. It's nothing serious
Lady Artemis you honor me
Hey, how'd you get your hands on a nice bow like that?
You take good care of corn out for me. So I can try it too once you're up here. I stole it for my dad
I don't like those creatures either. They're so annoying. Yeah, they just like bum rush you. Okay. Your attack is stronger
I'm gonna do my attack is stronger because I've been having to use that more
I
Haven't been using the volley as much. I'll do that the dead better hide
I'm Zagreus aren't I something? Oh
Yeah, I thought I could dodge that
I
Damn it. Oh, I forgot
Oh as I fucked that up for myself. I hate these guys are my least favorite enemy in this game
I want to prefer to save my what I need to do with my strat is I need to save my deft defied until I get to Megara
At least I can talk to Zeus. Hopefully Zeus can give me something good because I would like an AOE
Just great
What the frick is this?
Oh god, I'm stuck. I'm stuck. Oh god. Oh god. I don't like this at all
Oh, oh lord Jesus
Jesus christ. I
Oh
Oh, I can run across stuff. Oh sick
Um
Anyways
Uh, I love having only three fucking health left. Sorry two health left. That's great
Can I get a critical please?
I should get a critical for one of the little guys
What is happening?
That run wasn't good because I didn't really get a lot of good boons to be honest with you
Oh
That blasted doomstone
Hi Raina
Are you gonna come snug
I want to try to get to Megara again
I'm stuck
Raina hold on. I'm trying to put my blanket on my lap so you don't accidentally scratch me
There you go
Good lady. Yeah, I could pop a squat now. Hi sweetness. What do you want to hug? I can give you a hug. Oh hug time
Hug to Raina
Sorry, she's on my shoulder. She called it my lap and called it up my shoulder to give me a hug
You smell stinky. Are you in a litter box? Wait
Hmm
She looks all offended that I'm sniffing her. I think I'm gonna
Wipe you down because I think it's
I think it's the medicine. She just smells like medicine because I've been giving her medicine
Can you give me some medicine?
Oh, my cat's food is about to go off
Doomstone more like boo stone
Little guys don't do damage. The big guy chains laser the small ones in fixed directions. Yeah, I think I figured that out
That's why I was targeting him
But thank you
Hmm
And boomi's not back on my desk boomi, can you lay down in the bed?
Can you not try to attack my wires? I'm covered in cats right now. I have cat hair in my face from right up
And she pulled my headphones out now I gotta stick my headphones back in
Okay
This I can't hear anything
These headphones are nice
The first time you give a book guys, you're telling me things that I've already figured out
Oh
Looks like you ran smack into the doomstone out in Tartarus think
I'm no I'm dumb and blonde, but I'm not that dumb and blonde. How goes it?
Why does this room feel weirder? I like the room got bigger. Your enemy is not the wretched dead and not your father
The underworld itself
Sorry, I'm reading was that there before?
Hi dad go to your room. Oh, okay
Who is that?
Who is that? Oh cat's food is going off
Let me help you get down this arena
There you go
Cat food dispenser my beloved
Tip shields can block damage what? No, I can block damage with a shield
No way bro. I had no idea you could rock damage with a shield
Not that that's the purpose of a shield or anything. I had no idea. Holy crap. Thank you guys. I appreciate it
Nix sometimes I get the impression the olympians look down on those of us born of the underworld
The gods of mount olympus tend to think themselves above us child
I can't imagine him otherwise
All right, let's reflect. How am I looking?
I'm going to save so I can have greater reflex
Um, I still don't have enough keys. I haven't really ran into any keys
Skelly I feel like you're up to something
Leave it at that now. Let's see it break some of these bones, huh?
It's kind of weird how much he wants you to hurt him like I know he gets paid for it, but like I'm good
Is there anything? Uh, let me see
That one looks interesting
Oh
Because then I can get really good crit stuff
Cool cool cool. Nice
It's actually a really cool boon. I will definitely try to find a nectar so I can give it to Poseidon because that would be probably really good
Tip the number at the bottom left should be hitting through there. Okay, got it. Thank you
That's gonna be I didn't know that before I thought that was just there for show
Normally it's for killing things, but in your case it makes it even easier for me to hunt you down
What are you gonna give me? What?
It said it would give me rare stuff you fuck
You lie to me
Okay, at least I can get a key people time when they are killed. No, you're lying
You're lying to me what the fuck I could have sworn there was another dude like in this corner over here
I
Got okay. I got attacks. I got oh sweet Daedalus
I like this game
Hi, how are you?
I would give you hot girl wrench, but I'm killing skulls
Give me a moment
I
Okay, this is like the choke point from before
Ow
I don't care about them. I just care about oh
Come on. There we go
Is bunny lady, that's me. I'm the bunny lady. How are you doing chill a dino has been spotted
You're unvulnerable with that block up from that direction even may lays get drunk what
Names are so you know their names. Just let you know since it's so well
It is
Yeah, I names what's a name I have no idea
Monsters don't go to hell with their kills smack that bow with a hammer. What's the worst that could happen?
The lady has been given a wrench
It's just the edge I need okay, um whole attack shoot rapidly but I can't power shot
No, I don't like that
Holds
I'm gonna charge folly
Oh brother
Okay, I want to get one of these because I want to give one to Poseidon because Poseidon I really like his dash
Can you touch my ears? Okay, only you only you can touch my ears. I'll give you I'll let you touch him because you're so cute
It is a privilege only given to a select few
I'm just gonna shoot at nothing
Oh
Oh frick I got stuck on the table
All right, at least that worked out perfect sweet sweet literally because it's nectar. Ha ha
No fair
Yeah, I'm lying about it everybody only Tio can touch my ears. You can't
Ha ha ha and the other girls from my my you know
The girls that I deem for the which is all of them. Just like you guys because you guys are trash
Oh great here we go. What is this? Oh my lord have mycy on me, please
What is this portal thing? It's locked. How will I ever know?
Oh, what the frick am I doing? I didn't mean to dash. I meant to oh, I was a cute girl. I'm nervous
I don't know how to act. I'm I'm underperforming at performance anxiety
What's the portal for though
It looks so soft my ears are very soft. They're like velvet
Even better than velvet. Why is the money locked? I have oh, I don't have enough points, probably
Zesty oh, can I please get up? What the heck?
What does that do?
I bet that
I'm generally interested in what that actually does for me
Ever no one will notice I'm underperforming everybody's watching me. I'm gonna pee myself
I'd love to take the portal but I don't have enough
Would it just bring me to magura? I feel like it would make another key
Someone's there. Well, I'll never find out
I
Might die this run again, I'm getting shitty boons
I actually have to play well
No freaking don't go behind the pillar. Oh freak. I didn't mean to do that
I can use this to unlock a weapon. Oh perfect Poseidon. Oh, yes, perfect. Oh freak. I only have 10 health though
It brings you to a special character. She literally cannot take the portal
She already learned to blame the boons. Oh, no
Oh, why?
I'm not gonna make it
Oh
Fuck I forgot
I don't care about little dudes
Oh
I don't want to fuck this up
I fucked it up
Damn that thing is hard to deal with if I had the dash I would
I if I had a if I just had a better dash, I think I would do better or if I had a better um
Something or other it's fine
I want to give the boon to Poseidon because I feel like he had something good
They know as much as weird
Uh, I don't want to talk to hip-nose because he's just fucking fucking shits on me each time
So how did it go?
In that case, I'll spare you the details
Fine
Your failure is quite easily
Sorry, I read fast
Even though I love the voice acting
I happen to know whom I should thank for the weapons just outside my chambers
Short kinks. Maybe like bullet hells. Well, you're in hell and there's a lot of damaging hit boxes
Let's charge time in the bow would be nice. Yeah
No Poseidon dash and run go next
If you hit the pillars off times you break it
Had no idea
Oh
Finally I'll fucking talk to you. Hey, you keep dying you happen to run into my brother anywhere out there by any chance
I haven't seen him in ages. What's with the long assignment?
Something about a war
Father sent Thanatos to take stock, but you're right. It's been a while now that you mentioned it
Where are you?
Let's see what else
Everything under control sure
I can
Drive money too pricey for me
Deep rising up a me
I've changed the color. I'd rather fix the lounge
I'd rather do like repair rather than
Whatever
Oh my god, let's do so. Oh, she's so cute. Let me just go talk to her
Oh my god
So
Do you want to go on a date with me because I would go on a date with you
Oh, uh, drink sometimes sounds wonderful. Do so. Maybe tomorrow assuming I'm not getting out of here by then
It's no big deal. I mean forget I asked I'm flirting with a head. Can I use her as an onahole? I mean what?
I can actually romance Tusa. Oh my god. I wish she didn't fly away
Oh
I like how this shroud just like smiled at next and then left
What do you mean she be no she be yes she be yes
I still don't have enough for the catholic vitality rena
You're sitting on me. I need to scratch my leg
And you're standing right where I need to scratch. Okay. Thank you
I need to sit up straight my posture is shit
It's some tigal bitties. Sorry. Let's go with this one. I didn't mean to do that
drop something
I have a bag
Well, I can't get it back. Oh, I can give a gift to him interesting. Can I romance skelly?
Which to choose uh
To rank up interesting
Go with that one again. Thank you for giving this back to me
He gives you a great trinket. I want to give a gift beside him first
Or aphrodite
Oh aphrodite
No, no, no, I hold I'll hold myself back
She's so hot look at her cheekbones among the gardens of Olympus here. I love her little rose headdress singing
Yeah, give me that fucking passion dash. Oh, I don't know I did that
Oh
Baby
Yeah, I love the dash stuff. I can't see past this fucking statue
Must stay focused men do not lose sights
I
Thank you so I can get health or health
What does it matter if I'm at full health?
Oh my god, I'm like a little sparkle fucking princess over here. What the hell? I love it
This game is so pretty. Hi me. Well, hold on frick. I needed to do another hot girl wrench
How fast can I do it?
Okay game paused I didn't know I could pause the game
All the cuties are out in full full force today. Oh my god
I'm gonna I'm afraid I'm gonna underperform again because it's a cute girl watching
I like how the skulls are like, huh?
Oh
Get the freaking aoe
I was trying to dash out the way
Yeah
No, no, oh frick. I need to go to the choke point
Okay
Come on
Oh, I didn't mean to dash forward. There we go a centaur heart
Do I get drew let's get more of these I'm looking for hours. I just got shy I've been performing well. Oh
Oh
I'm blushing you can't tell because I can't reach my toggles right now, but I'm blushing so much
Actually, I'm gonna stay on the side
I always love my little lurkers
Especially if they're cute girls
No, wait, let me just
Make it so you guys can't get over here and jump at me
Oh
I really like this game. Uh, oh d. Los hammer. Let's freaking go
I'm gonna melt under the pressure
Oh
This is a bad area
I don't have anybody to shoot at
Now now
I got me in the freaking choke point
I don't know. I keep pressing the wrong button. Uh, let's see a special fire. I might
Do four plus shots
The triple shot was actually helpful because it locked onto multiple targets
Uh
I do like that
I
Where is the hundred I cleared that last map for you, baby girl
Uh, I don't really need to go to the shop. So I'd rather get a key so I can unlock that little pitchy fork
Oh frick
I need to get them to walk on this I can shoot it
Come on
Yeah, there we go
Perfect
No
Come over here big guy come on sweet hot
Oh just for you just for you
That hit me. Oh, I guess I did a key to a weapon
What does this mean? Which way this way because I don't know what it means and I'm curious
I mean the mods discord not nitro
what
How much you miss all the time triple shot is a no brainer root you dick
I
Don't even have discord nitro. Who are you?
Are you freaking sisyphus?
Oh, it is
Oh, I didn't get to read that on a little strollers all
Do me a favor though. You see the fury sisters. Let them know. I accidentally moved my knee and I bumped my
Hand to press the button. Oh, I'll let them know. We'll write. I hear you loud and clear your highness
Why is that rock have a smiley face on it? You take care
I
Got my guy
Oh
What your life total is 68 out of 75 lose it all for an express trip back to the house of hades. Why would I want that?
Used to permanently go stronger
Why
It's boldy what
Wait, so I'm kind of confused. So if I talk to him, he just gives me something or is he gonna send me back to hades if I click
this one
Let's find out. Oh shit
Cheers mate
The underworld's power. Oh, actually that was good. Oh aphrodite
Oh, god, is am I gonna talk to this thing again?
Okay, I won't kill you. Okay, cool. You can do it. Oh, thanks, Sisyphus
Oh freaking hell
I kind of wish I had the Hermes around for this
Yeah
Oh
Why did I stand there?
Anyone else
Anyone else that was pretty badass people die when they're killed
Oh special deals were
I
Can max out my life do I get more life empty inside
I feel like I get more life, don't I permanently
I need an answer. I don't think the wrong thing on accident
Her weak effects have longer duration
I
Take a sippy while I wait for you guys to catch up in the ball
Raina you're so cute
Oh, and they give you more you get more in the future. Okay, I thought it permanently raised my life
I'm not gonna do that. Then I'm going to do the empty inside the longer duration because then
Wait, I thought that would make this longer
I don't know whatever it is or really fucking matter
This is helpful against them
Is there a bone thing no
Oh, what the hell? Oh
Oh, we shouldn't walk on this out
Sure
No, I thought that was gonna be I would like more boons
Why don't I just knock down? Frick Raina you're falling off of my lap
Okay, let's just hop down
Hold on. I need to get more comfy
Can't believe this game has a pause. I'm not used to games with pauses
I
Still haven't beaten those stupid twin things and
Elden ring because I haven't played since
My last stream, but I'm probably gonna do that
After these
No, not you fuckers. Oh, I swear to god. Oh, no
Oh frickin hate you guys
Oh
They have so much reach
Okay, I'm getting the timing right
Oh, why did I turn around? Oh, fuck this fucking
These have too much range in my opinion
I was hoping I could get to lane with spikes
Come on
No, why'd you walk around it
I
All right, let's get the poem
Yeah, that's when virgins
I stand behind here I could probably
Walk
Yeah, I could walk him there right on cue
She's stuck in there. Oh, that was weird
Oh, fuck me
Okay
Extra blessing
I woke up and madame is winning as she is
Oh shout with aries to buy something
Oh, that's not what I meant
I spy everything because I have the money
Where the fuck am I
Yeah
Now
Yeah, I think I thought if I I can't really hit them that well with the arrow
I think it's easier to deflect stuff with the fucking uh
With the dash or with the
Or with the sword in my opinion
Because I feel like and obviously what's with the fucking shield
Ow and realize that the moment I stepped on it
I might die for this one
I
Because it's hard to shoot those things out of here
Hey, what's up aries let's fucking go
And one shot back in the war. Oh fuck. Yeah, please do take care of it. I do
Athena dashes great deflect
She didn't invest in the dash. Yes. I did invest in the get dash. What are you talking about?
I can get this again
I kind of want this again
Kill or be killed because I don't I haven't had anything for my special
Um, so I can get shmoney
Or I can get shmoney
Wait, did I accidentally click the other one?
Do you want to attack us here for bow? Well too bad I didn't
Oh, hey
Yeah
That's such a sick outfit though. He reminds me of the ghoul
From fall out. Hey, what's that you got some sort of ways for sale? Hey, what's that?
I don't have any money
I'll take that
Frick I do not have enough money to beat megara
Shit
Had I known I can't well who the fuck cares buy it. Anyway, it's a steal from him
Oh no
Bro
You are so hot your whip's not been all that persuasive in the past. Do we have a history?
Brother, excuse me. Maybe persistence will pay off for both of us
She don't mean it and she she definitely don't mean
Ow, how'd she hit me with that?
Oh
Wait, I forgot to have this. Oh fuck. Oh fuck
Oh, I just got anxious
Stop chasing me bitch
Oh my god
No, frick
Did I pick up my thing I don't even know oh I've two of them now she did not have these powers before
Wow
Are you gonna keep going
Whips and change excite me come come come come on. Oh
Ow
Oh, I thought I could run out see I that's where I need the extra fucking dash. Uh, so that's why I'm gonna buy next
I'm actually I think I might she got me. I'm very determined to beat megara
I don't talk to you you again. Everybody's being such a dick
Why I can scarce believe my art is everybody just sarcastic
Anything you say to me you save
Everybody's just me the fury got you again. She is unstoppable, isn't she one time
I tried to stop her on the way to have a chat with your dad and she didn't even turn her head
No, actually I'm happy I talked to you that time
Killies I
Sometimes I fear that father if he somebody is doing fireworks
Your father's still getting caught up with work that I created for him in my mortal days
Or it's the ops. I'm sorry. There's nothing he can take from me. We have a mutual arrangement. He and I
Oh, yeah, we're we're gonna beat make the stream. I'm determined. You're right
I'm very determined
Oh wait, I want to talk to her
I
I just wanted to apologize because I think maybe I didn't act very appropriately last time you spoke to
Deucer, please. There's no need to apologize
I can't wait to use your head as an ono
You really needed
Thank you. Thanks so much
Tee hee hee she's so cute
Me me me me me
Hi pretty lady your hair is the night and I think that's like my favorite part is you have the night sky in your hair
That's so cool. I'll see you. I wish I could do that, but it wouldn't make sense because I'm a bunny
I don't think there'd be bunnies in my hair
Leave her alone. What do you mean? She's I love her
I love Deucer
Can't afford that. I didn't mean to click that. I'm going to click that. Um
I can I can boost this again feeling good. Okay
Go lie down
The hell
It is the dead of night or the approximation of my sleepwalking
Prince of the underworld Zagreus rises from a fitful slumber with much mischief on his mind
Mischief me I was just going to have a little look through father's stuff. Damn, okay
All is quiet at this time
Ever dreaming hypnos put a spell upon the house as willful Zagreus had asked of him
All are fast asleep say for the prince. Excuse me, but why did I wake up exactly lower your voice old man?
I'm trying to be sneaky here
He ventures toward the stately throne of his lord father
Half expecting to be caught
But he'll expecting what he is about to find
I said shut up old man
Daddy's gone. He does not know exactly what he seeks
He only knows that something always has fell to off to him
But he does not belong
Oh, it's a flashback. Oh lord ades never would indulge such questions
So prince who are my parents? Who's my mom?
I'm not listening. Tell me about my mother
The rifles through his lord father's possessions. There is not much of any import there
ledgers and administrative department work
Okay, maybe not because I'm suddenly getting tired reference to his son. I will try
With core knocked by my side, I can do anything
but then
There is the note
Written finally in a hand and voice the likes of which my mom is a Persephone
Hades
I can no longer tolerate my life here in this place
So I'm leaving even if it kills me
I won't be returning to olympus
If there is a place where I belong in this world
It must be so my mom abandoned me great
Perhaps it's like I should love some meat
Take care of Cerberus
I shall miss him
Persephone
Mom
The prince of the underworld Zagreus
Absorbed the contents of this hidden letter
Written in his mother's hand. Hey, how does he know it was his mom?
My mother's hand. Wait what?
You're saying this Persephone that she's my
The narrator spoiled it
But father always said that nix was
That liar
He lied to you wait. He lied instead that my grandmother was my mom
That was that's kind of weird. That means that Hades would have fucked his dad
I mean
His mom
Wait, no Hades is a son of yeah, nix and uh
That titan right? I don't know
Thos did the prince
Inevitably the world kept truth about his lineage entirely by chance. Nice job narrator slash Homer
I like how I'm like 3d, but not it's very interesting the one time queen of all the underworld
Where had she gone and why?
Engulfed by newfound questions and this rage
Leave me alone
Well, I still
I hope not. I hope he didn't
Nix you why
How could you you
You're nix you're not my mother
All this time you and my father you you lied to me. Ow is some elbow. Oh my dear child
Oh, so now you know new art. So now you know
But only half the truth. I can explain the rest so
please
I love the half moon
Love the starlight in her hair. She's literally my favorite design
Oh
My arm mother I wonder do you hear that my arm fucking popping
Yeah, why is there no mention? She's look after the dog. Fuck my son. Don't fuck my son like that, but like fm
I don't know what I'm saying
Hey pal
Nothing is off limits for the greek
Oh, I can lock this though. Let's see. What's in here for alpha the eternal spear. Oh my pursuit. Oh shit
Holds then release
Yo
Yeah, that was nothing
Sorry, I'm very excited phrasing
They cook every day. I believe the minds of this came out me with this myth. Oh someone tell them the fuck
I never used desk dash attacks. I should probably do that
I said, I think it's the awkwardness of the bindings
Damn that is actually sick
You caught that a kid
Oh, there's a max cool
All right
Interesante by everyone
Family oh death is your only family death and I
I
Best to get accustomed to the both of us
Like how his laurels are on fire just like mine. I didn't notice that before not on your life
Poseidon I can give you a gift. I've been waiting for this my entire life
Uncle Poseidon, it's been excellent to know you sir. So please this is for you. I think this might be the run boys
Oh
Oh, I am positively moved
Oh my god, my I
Dispenser is going off and scared me sound like someone knocking on my door
I thank you, uncle. You got a conch shell
If you your cruel father Hades, he's my elder brother, you know that
Yeah, we talked about this last time
Tidal dash, baby
Tidal dash
Wait, what's flood shot though
You can't tell but I'm biting my lip and like the f-boy way
Uh, okay
Damn if I could get this in the flood shot, that'd be so good
Hmm
Choice, yeah, emoji is perfect. That's exactly what I was doing
Mmm, I need a lip bite toggle
I know
I don't even smile when I'm like
When I bite my lip, it's just my mouth is closed
Oh, it's kind of doing it now
I'm wiggling my eyebrows. I can't tell if you can tell
It's actually really hard you have to be like do you very exaggerated with your eyebrows
All right. Well, we're gonna stick with the true and tried
Tidal dash, baby. Oh wait, I'm doing this like it's a fucking
Okay, this might not be the run because I don't have the bow, but it's fine
Because I already fucked it up
What the hell oh
Interesting uh
Uh
Dash dash dash
Oh
Poseidon again. Oh god, here we go. I was so hoping we get oh wait, there's a portal fuck
I'll never know
I'm used to the oh
If I can get my special to be
A little bit more powerful this might be helpful
Oh because I get like locked in the animation
So
Don't decide it from Olympus. I accept this message
Your boons do you have more damage and siphon?
Oh, that's literally what I asked for I asked for more damage for my special and I'm getting it
The dash strike for this weapon is the main draw bows kind of whack anyways, I like the bow shut up
Cast is a lot harder use consistently with you needing to run around pick them back up dash is more consistent
Yeah, I like it. That's a good point. Um
I just need to get used to the fucking spear
Can I charge it
Hello
Get dead
I like how I essentially have fucking Poseidon's tried it
Oh
This also goes through multiple enemies, so I like that a lot. It's gonna knock something back home. Oh, baby
Daedalus hammer. Hello. What the fuck I'm stuck on these spots
Oh, I need to do that. I will keep you at arm's length
Where oh
Oh, yeah, I like this
I can just dash around these bitches
I like it now to fix up this spear
I can get this triple jab
I
Have I don't really use dash a dash strike a lot
I like this I like the triple the spread because it helps me focus on more than one enemy at once
I don't want to jinx the run, but I'm feeling good
Oh fuck I didn't think he was gonna
How does he reach me? I didn't think you would have that much fucking. Oh my fucking god
I need to get money so I can buy health that's for sure
This hard place to dodge
I
Should be useful. Oh, thank god give me this fucking health. I swear to god
Mmm fucking up. I'm fucking up
Come on
Oh
My nose is a G
Aphrodite sweetheart, what do you have for me?
I need a special from her that's all I I just needed something I just need a special
I
Have a backstab that's good
I just like doing this the specials great
Oh fuck yeah
Yeah, you've had a brush with mega the fury haven't you? Oh, I know a thing or two about that one
Yeah, we Olympians no longer mean we Olympians
You're the only exception
She's a very interesting place. Um, so I can get a call
That would be helpful against mega
Oh
It's only five seconds, but it might be helpful
Oh, let's talk to her again. Hello
Oh
God, no, not you you fucking fucking fucking no rena that was off the time rena
In the name of Hades
I
Think I just need some
I need some help
Great
All right time to dash for 45 seconds
Oh no
All right, I'm pulling all my headphones. Oh
Oh
My god
I can't believe I read into that
I
Have a one health
Raina don't you on my headphones. I swear to god
I don't trust you. I I I'm sorry
And I have to
She like hopped up on my desk
I wish there was gonna be health in the shop, but there wasn't
Oh, man
I
Yeah, I just oh fuck I forgot I had death to fight it
Oh, I hate these guys
Oh
I don't know why he's going over there, but go off son
Don't come back
Still not enough to beat Megara
What
No, I need the health I need the health
What the frick
What is this? Oh god
Why did that hurt me I was dashing
Can't even get to these fucking guys
Is he dead? Okay, yes
Oh, come on
Oh
That's a relief
I think his dash means have to I missed the health on the floor fuck me bro. I didn't know that
God's grant me strength
Okay, I'm shopping my senses. Okay. Um
It is what it is
Oh, hello
And there you are again, I love her voice so much let you run a muck in his domain like this
Uh, I wasn't paying attention. I was more focused on living
Oh
What the fuck why was it aiming the wrong way? Oh my god
I don't use my fucking
Oh
That hurts that hurts that hurts so bad
Those fucking spikes I get so caught up in what looking at where she is and I'm not looking where I'm going
The sealed weapons by your chambers your father won't observe their absence. I don't think
They remind him power that once sealed away the Titans
I do like the sphere a lot though
The heck is this you're late with your report hypnos again. Oh, I think that's look like that
The dead of course can wait. Oh, well, let's see. I woke up. I don't know what time it was and
He's like floating that every shade had been accounted for just like I always do except I couldn't find my list at first
Can you believe it into the blast at port already? I don't have all day or night
Hmm
Third time's the charm. I hope
My list I found it over by the lounge it was inside but I am not the one who put it there
No, sir, so I've been making positively sure it's not been tampered with that it adds everybody's name cause of death
Plays a bird from her body weight any previous allergies or medications
Well, aren't you just the sweetest
Anonymous tip ten dollars. Thank you anonymous alert. Please ignore
You can dash over gaps and destroy the purple projectiles from the is health and repeated normal attacks
Conform combos and can be chained with dash
I knew that I knew I could do that
Because I've I noticed that I did it accidentally a few times
um
I might try harder to train chain stuff, but
I guess my first time playing the game
I'm not too worried. I'm kind of you know hanging out. Thank you for the tip though
John Hades, I thought I was John Hades
Yikes, you've done it now hip-nose. Ooh get fucked hip-nose
Here's the fee the fated list of minor prophecies. That sounds somewhat exciting. I suppose I like how they're just magically appears in my room
I can't get over there yet. Let's check in to see if I can do shit. Is this the door that I can get to? It's locked interesting
Oh
Nick's must be someplace else. It looks like she's uh boy of the month again
Hey, that must be the fated list. He has the best ash
That definitely came to pass
My extended family seems an interesting lot
Oh
Okay, wait, let me actually read these the sun of the gods. That's something free from the realm when she was born. Okay
There was an underworld. Okay, this is just bonuses. Oh my god, I'm into Athena
Okay
I
Need keys
Cool
Hey, yeah something back there for you pal
Another weapon. What the heck is that?
That a giant claw
Can't open this yet. Yeah, but I want to know what it's called. I bet it's like servers is claw or something stupid
That's kidding. It's probably not that. Let's see what that one does
Please I honestly might use this a lot because I really like Poseidon's boons. Um, this sounds funny
Uh, I'll grab. I don't want to do this with this
No, I don't feel like doing that with that one
Oh skelly, I'll give you a gift
For you, mate. I thought you might get a kick out of this
For me pal
Oh, the sparkles are on his face. He's so happy. I got this for you
Cheers, mate. You got me a tooth. Oh, you shouldn't have no really you shouldn't have
Hitting a while out there boyo. Hey, I know the fee
Yeah, it's skelly. It's tough. What does this fucking tooth do?
The smiley oh
Interesting
I wish I could do two keepsakes as once is that a thing do you get to do two keepsakes?
It's called the Thanos gauntlet
That's who this berry because like
this on top of the
Death thingy is pretty good
um
I'll do that actually I'll take that lucky tooth
Time to go
Hey, Athena, please be next. Oh, we're Poseidon
Hey, you get Poseidon another gift. I don't know how that works
Or other gifts other people
I really need to talk to you. Um
I'm gonna do the tempest flourish this time because I could be like, oh
Really you wait, I thought that was my special wait, huh? I'm confused
Um
Am I missing something did that just bug out isn't my special supposed to be an area of attack
Am I tripping am I?
Oh wait, no, it's this that's right. Okay. Sorry. I'm stupid. I forgot. I thought it was I'm stupid
Let's see how quickly I can slay you all pretty fast
Oh
Let's go
I throw is a special. I know I don't know why I thought it was the cast
This is good
Oh, there's so many others along the way
Oh
Please accept this up you know, I'll give you a little gift if you give me a little gift
And I am feeling generous as well. So here a small chat delay higher for the stream. Yeah, it is
I have to figure out why the fuck it's doing that
You have my thanks lord Ares
You're the son of knight herself they say that's a lie. Um
Yeah, I think I need to start checking before
When I immediately do my waiting rooms because I think
Automatically like my template is set to latency and I need to fix that. I didn't set it up my manager did so
I need to sort that out
You the blades all fuckies are good. Um, because I'm debating whether to do this or I'm I need I need a dash. I need a dash
Yeah
I'm gonna need a I'm gonna need a dash
Should I get that or a key?
Get the key because I would like to unlock the claws
So wait, that's not something I can
I thought it was gonna hit him in time, but
What the fuck I thought it hit him
Jesus Christ
It's Jason born, okay, can I have something other than money? Oh fina. Hello
You
Keep baiting me fuck
I'm indebted to you goddess for all that you and your side of the family have done for me
Here's a gift for you
We're cousins. I wish we you to have this with my compliments
I love how the Hades me John is Mediterranean prog
Nobody helps you. He wants to be a wolf of closet kid. Hey
Hotter and different lore what?
Lady Athena, thank you
I
Notice that some of them blank and some of them don't they can get any hotter than this look at this woman
Unless they give her some cheeky side boob
Which is the best one
Yeah, I said it hotter, which is the best one one of the prophecies in the fatalist indicates you will choose this
Oh
Wait till you'll see redacted. Yeah, there's no reflect ash
Oh, is it only is it only um
Everybody's saying one
All right
Jimmy, I love you. Please do the nine
clears in order to complete the main story in a single stream
I don't think I can do that
All right
Oh fuck Jesus Christ, uh
I
Don't feel like dealing with that. So we're gonna go this way. Oh, it's early access. Oh, okay
This isn't as strong as I wanted it to be. Oh, what the frick bro
Oh
Can I have some help what does this portal do I can't even fucking go through it again looks like I'm talking to Athena
I just want to go to the portal
So
Does he just get stun locked? Okay
He's sick, that's what you get in the name of Hades
Oh resist damage from traps
I think I need that
Uh
You cast
Oh, fuck E me me me me moe
Catch a tiger by the toe if he hollers let him go out
Goose why one? Okay. That's what I thought. All right
I
Just want to
Oh, yeah, that's right. Ever got that does that because I got that before. Oh, let me get a palm
Oh, baby. Whoa, fuck
I'm literally dashing
Oh
Oh, fuck
Can I get some health?
Palmed up, let me see
She's realizing this thing with stun locks. Can I give you a gift? I feel like it'll give me something nice
Now hold a moment highness. I cannot accept something like this. Oh, yeah, can we get a palm?
Thanks for that, sir. Thank you for a shattered shackle
You know prince said I've not expected to run into you. I like how he calls me zed because like z for British people is zed
I've had much company of late as well. Well, something's just about always in this back home, sir
Well, I am grateful for it. I am the old boulder there in turn
I'm used to going lengthy stretches on my own, but having he is a buff dude
His expression is kind of off-putting though
What is he chained to is he chained to the boulder?
I got you covered. Oh, thank you
Can I have some more?
It's sissy puss. Bye
Oh
Stun lock, okay. Yeah, the stun lock is nice
Oh, health or hammer health or hammer
I need the health
or do I
Because I still have
The watch I'ma call it
I still have I have the tooth
And I have the have the health thing
Hmm
What do you guys think what do you guys think you think the hammer I'm thinking the hammer too
Just because I think I have enough
Don't need HP if you don't get hit
I'm gonna go hammer
No, fuck
Oh
Fuck I didn't mean to deftify here
Because I'm not paying attention to them
I
Didn't mean to press that
Up to seven foes
Yeah
Up to seven foes. Are you kidding me? It just bounces between them
Oh
Oh, baby
Fuck
Oh
Hello darkness my old friend, oh
Should I see a feet? Well, I could get more health from this
Fuck it
Oh
I can't run I should not be the supervisor here
Darkness
I need to get that
Baby
All right, let's
When I first notified lord father's use and other members of our family of your existence agrius
No
What the fuck where did he come from
Interesting
Oh
This is obviously I should do the unshakable metal right boss damage reduction 10 percent
Raina, why are you just standing in front of my computer? She's just standing on front of my keyboard
Yeah, yeah, yeah, let's go team. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh
Whoa, baby
Okay, I'm ready you guys can't see how fucking maniacal I look right now
I'm back make
What are you doing Zach?
Okay, I just want to make sure that I can pause during things because rain is circling me like she wants to snuggle and I'm like
I need to be able to pause
I love her voice so much
If I had this and the thing that makes enemies drop health from the store I would have been unstoppable
The range of noises she reaches me
I'm your dad's partner
Oh
Yeah
I keep running into that stuff
Oh
Fuck oh, fuck I'm fucking up. I'm fucking up. I'm fucking up. I'm fucking up. I'm fucking up
Oh, why why
Oh
Okay, don't panic when she throws her little shits
Oh, stop
Oh
I love her darkness
No effect
Oh
No
Damn you Meg
I'm so close
I'm so sad
I
Need the moment that I saw her aoe attack and I got stuck in the corner that it was just not going to be a good time
No, I should have beaten her
You never learn I don't want to talk to anybody. I just I don't find giving shit
The fates are betting print. Oh no, not this determinism thing again
I
Mad I'm mad. Hey
Mad excellent
I
I'm ready
Hello there Dionysus
Hmm
Thank you Dionysus mate
Sometimes I have to wonder
I
Time to feast
May I help you
I
Got it
What else
I
Fuck well miss a couple coins
So all I need to do is sacrifice some of my life essence to go in here. Sorry just associated for a second
Who or what is that?
Is this chronos? This is not someone I recognize
So in the name of Hades
Hello, may I ask who's calling?
You
That is the coolest fucking design I've ever seen in my life, holy shit
I the artist is such a great job, holy crap the weird ethereal
The faces the eyes very
Wow
Oh, it's chaos
Like how the world is in their hand
Each time I attack get hit for five
That doesn't really make so I just want to be able to use my attack
I'll have to withstand the whims of chaos to extract the benefit within the underworld's quietest mode and best take all the evidence I find
I just think
Who's next
I
Surprised I didn't stun lock them like before only stuns lock them when they don't have their armor
Oh
I dashed how would I I guess I'm not impervious
You found me out of us
Puri down and talk to us has been a real problem
Let's hunt some dead
Oh
That's something
I'd rather if it was hell I'd do it
I need better boons, but I don't feel like dealing with the frickin whatever's
I
Think I hear the river
Much better
Here on you've been such a reassuring sight I thought I'd offer you a token of my gratitude
Wait, you don't have to give me something in return
I don't know what to say mate
Find a to you as well there mate
The infernal wares of the stygian botan carrom lies that would be me
Oh
Can I please get some health
And I please get some health lost souls with nowhere left to turn congregate in deepest to tartarus
Where they fuse together with the earth itself into odious
Oh sharon is just like
They basically turn into big crystals
So
I had this with the seven
Now would be perfect my ears itchy
Oh my god itchy
Oh
How am I still alive
Okay, I get datalus
It's okay. That's all I want. I want that anyways
Let's see. Let's see. Let's see. Let's see. Let's see. Let's see
Oh
More coming
I
Haven't been using my massive spin because it just walks me in an animation that slows me down
This will make me have three critical hits so this will be pretty good
I
I'm gonna see dianis again. I haven't been using my thing. I totally forgot that I had that
I'll be honest with you. What is the fucking music? I'll talk to dianis this again
I
I'm kind of fun. I need a dash. I'm gonna get the dash
Because I'm about to go fighter so it's just I need the dash
All right, hello, I'm sorry I'm gonna be locked in
Oh
How does she still get the fucking hit me
So
Just ran into that
Oh
Bro, I fucking hate her so much
Oh, you win this round make I don't understand
Why am I so shit at this game? It's pissing me off
You got
Hey, old prince, I have to say lord authorizing transfer the know that
Well, that's the spirit. I suppose I wouldn't mind their help. I guess or shame
Hey, uh, father, why don't you get this you think you can
You're welcome father
Oh why he doesn't fucking give me anything dick
Nick's I have to ask you something
Your mother yet lives there can be no other explanation
For it. I think I turned out okay
Um, thanks
I don't blame the boons because I could have won with the boons I had
Show me something new
Nice felt that I think
It's like any one of the runs I could I should have beat her I should have beat her
What's this one do I'm keeping the lucky tooth. I think
It's just Dionysus and I just get boons
although I like
Sisyphus is good
To be honest when you get like when you feel like you're gonna have a shit run. That's what it's good for
I need to lean back. Oh my fucking legs
operations increased I don't really know what that means but sure go off
You're really good. No, I don't think I am though. Like I know I can be fucking better than that. It's pissing me off
I know I can be better. What the hell? I didn't mean to press that. I know I can be better. I'm gonna press those
I
What's up handsome, let me give you a piece of advice for you. You're gonna cross a guy like me out there
You just give him a good stab right in the back without a second the most interesting character
I
Just I wish I was one of those people that was just cracked at any game they touched. I know I know people like that
My weapons hidden talents
Oh
Oh, but that special is good
I'm gonna go with this though just change score again because it is just really nice to have
Oh
Each time the prince delves back into the underworld it's ever shifting chambers real up
Like I like the game a lot. I'm just mad that I'm shit at it
Oh
Why I'm sorry you're coming for me. I didn't lock on for some reason
It is simpler you have to really just like dumb it down in your head
I like how for airy sound it's like
I
Yeah, I'm in that doom. That'll be fucking perfect for that. All right
I don't know what doom means, but I like it
I've already like I've seen myself improve with the game. That's for sure
I don't think I need to go to
Oh
Oh my god, see that's what I mean. I hope I want to get a fetus thing
I didn't even get to this dude. Come here you fucking bitch
Why is it not properly locking on?
Come here you fucker
I
Don't know how you rank up a lucky tooth. I could see chaos, but I don't feel like it
I'm gonna see Poseidon. Hopefully he can get me the dash
I
My ex-girlfriend she just won't let me fucking leave bro. It's just fucking sucks dude
See God's might
Yeah, I got a good dash
Dash I'm coming in fast first place you're coming in fucking hell, bro
Oh
I do really like I'm happy I picked it. Oh, okay. We're gonna do another Poseidon. I mean areas
This I would have broken an armor
I had
Oh, why do I keep fucking running into those stupid bombs?
Um, every word I was saying
Every word I was gonna say I lost my train of thought doesn't matter
Oh no
Oh
Being a palm fuck it do the trial
That's enough there we are and my keep
Nope
I don't reach on that
I
Delicious
Stronger still
Are we leaving shortly
Oh
Where now
Karen's shop
I wish I had a little bit more money so I could
Get something from Aphrodite
I'm short of coin
Oh wait, but I got Sisyphus up there. It's fine. I had to ask I'll take this one
Oh
Hello your highness hey, is this of us you're actually perfect timing
Oh, that is quite an undertaking prince
So
Then here you go on my authority
Karen's shop
What am I supposed to do here?
Oh, I could have gotten obels and they could have bought shit. Damn. I didn't know who's gonna be next
Because it'll been great to get another palm
Buy this just to get the extra point of health
She's like this is like the fifth time you've been here
I'll make this quick
I'll kill you when you stand
Oh
I'll make you pay
Let's go
Killings might know what to do with this
I just killed somebody
I was getting pissed I was like dude if I don't beat her this time I'm losing it
Oh
Let's fucking go what how did you
Can wash away my bones
Okay
I want to keep playing
Does it auto save
Do I keep fighting if I quit
If I quit does it does it cancel everything I'm done I can save what can I save
I
Just don't save
This is projects progress saved a minute ago. I saved. Okay. I just kind of want to peek ahead though
No, I'll save it for next time. Okay
We beat her. I should have beat her sooner. I'm mad at myself for that
I really like this the sphere
Um, just a hit give up
Um
Is really good. I like the sphere
And
No, just
That's something I could interact with
None other than those in the trusted inner circle of lord hades are authorized to enter the intricate chambers connecting the vast regions of the underworld
But the prince decides to barge in anyway
Hmm
I barred where I please
So if I died and like if I proceeded is this the continuance of
Like what I used to get sent all the way back
Oh
Please you don't have to placate me. I'm not a child. I wasn't doing good. I could have been better
um
Because I want to go forward but I also don't
Because I'm tired you go to bed
Uh, I'll leave you here. I'll let my
It goes to the next realm
If I die in that realm
Do I get sent to the hub or do I have to start level one?
Okay, so if I die in level two
If you die start back at one, uh
You
Then how do I get to the hub from here?
Does that mean I would have to beat meg again
I
Thought the game would be a little bit more forgiving and then let you go on to the next level, but I guess it seems that you
It's one try or bust so you literally have to almost make a run
And
And a single go damn, that's hard. Um
We're under 30 minutes, okay
Damn
Hmm
Okay
We also have increasing benefits as you do it true you can become absolutely tapped
All right
Good to know you don't go to the hub. That's what the constructions are for to explain the floors variety
What do you mean the floors variety
Oh
Wait, so like for like if you want more things to show up or like this to happen or that to happen. Okay
I think we're in the first sub 20 minutes is doable
So I have to do this three more times there's four levels
Interesting
So I ha I would have to go back and beat meg again if I die
That's annoying
Oh, it's like sisyphus. No, yeah
I'm constructing a horse ring that we did
Oh
Zach can get hella broken. Okay. That's annoying. I don't want to fight her again
And others okay, interesting
Funny you say that
All right, I'm gonna pause it here then so I don't fuck up or run
Damn that sucks
I
Sick
That was fun
I like the game a lot. I did not realize how much I enjoy roguelites
I know someone uh, I know straw knee was like I should play biting of Isaac since I like called the lamb and I was telling her
She should play called the lamb since she was biting of Isaac
Um
Cool all right, thank you for uh
You might find me enjoy your early spot. He was like, uh level four gross. Uh, not this place again
Yeah, this is a great game. I didn't I'm wishing that I played it sooner
It's really good. I really like the spear. I think the spear is my favorite
I thought the bow was gonna be my favorite
But uh, I just have to wait until I get those gloves because maybe who knows
But I hope you guys have a good night. Hope you enjoyed. I'm sorry. Sometimes I would go to this non verbal
I just like I sometimes I just need to focus and I can't
Like um talk
It's hard for me to like give commentary and I'm just like no I just I just need to
Lock in bro
um
That was definitely
That was definitely due to I'm learning how the boons work and what stacks well
And that's good
Let's wish I played it sooner
I know because this game has been out for a bit and I've always I've seen the art of the character
I didn't think I would like the
Game style because I usually don't like birds. I view games
And I I realize I just need to give games a chance
I really do because I might not like because like again like I played balder's gate for like three hours sometimes
um
And I didn't end up liking it, but I bet if I tried again, I would like it a lot. I might try to play balder's gate
I don't have a PC though. I have one from my playstation
Same with um
Call the lamb. I didn't think I'd like it. I ended up loving it
And same with diablo. I had never played a diablo game before but I really really
Like the concept of the latest diablo game
And I ended up loving it. I was like, oh, let's just skyrim from a different viewpoint
I hope you enjoyed the tutorial. Oh damn if that's a tutorial, I'm gonna get my ass handed to me
I'm gonna go right back to the start
Mm-hmm. The focus of the log kid makes it much easier. Okay. Sometimes I feel bad when I can't talk
Uh, sometimes I just want to focus, but I'm glad you guys enjoyed
One of my classes in the world loves ma'am
That's all that scratching is
Balder's gate was indulged my interest. I didn't know uh, you could play with like more than one person
I thought it was like two people or something at the most
But cool. All right, I'll see you guys. I'm gonna go to bed
I wasn't gonna try to play elden ring after this, but I'm like, I think I'm good
I was like, I don't think I'm ready to try to grind to kill those stupid virgin abdicators
Uh, I'll probably do that in the morning
But tomorrow's sunday
Yeah, and I don't stream tomorrow. I'll probably
I'll probably I might do a gorilla depends of elden ring. Um, I also need to clean my house
I picked up a little bit today and I did my laundry, but I need to fold it and put away and that stuff
Because I just I really want to get to the dlc. I'm like, I'm taking forever to get to the dlc. Um
I'm excited to see like your promising app rabbit. Where's the app now have fun with the games? I don't know
I don't know everybody watches streamers differently. So
Yeah, have a good night everybody
I have a smash or pass tomorrow. I actually don't we had to move that to monday
I um, I just changed it
Uh, cuz toma is was actually she forgot she was doing a watch along
um
Of a show
I forget what show she's told me it was
But she she actually was ended up being busy. So we're doing it monday instead. I'm sorry. I should have tweeted that out. Um
I have a good night. Thank you guys for sticking with me. I really like this game. Thank you for just suggesting it to me
Um, keep suggesting me games. Please. Please suggest games you want me to play that you think I might like
Um, but yeah
Later
It smells like stinky stinky smell
The smelly smell
The smelly
So
You